salut tout le monde aujourd'hui le
podcast est présenté par police lippi
une compagnie québécoise de rayer de
matelot de stock pour dormir des
matelots xi qui répondent à tous les
budgets de toute une gamme dont le
matelas dans le matelot effet en fait
ils matelas sur lequel les candidats
d'occupation double dorment qui a été
fait pour les athlètes où les gens avec
des blessures
en fait c'est là où ce nano bio n'est
nano bionique qui utilisent qui
transforme en fait de la chaleur du
corps en rayon infrarouge qui permet une
meilleure récupération fait que si vous
êtes un athlète ou si vous êtes blessé
vous avez besoin de mer récupération
aussi vous êtes à eau des bd des
montagnes russes d'émotions aussi vous
avez besoin de bien dormir après les
twists de jay bybee slip c'est pour vous
puis on a un code promo on me dit que
c'est fait pour les athlètes mais aussi
pour les leaders
on a un code promo de 25% des rabais sur
tout sauf l est soumis le cas promo seo
la lettre au sans fil s 25 c jusqu'au 9
novembre
alors profitez-en qui vous serez pas
déçu de votre achat policiers merci la
guinée police les bombes à castres oui
une production du f mais elle nous sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut et que nos invités date 6 h quand
un avec moi d'hommes plantes
une bonne façon d'encourager gagne on le
dit on le répète on n'arrête pas d'en
parler sur notre page piquionne west
qu'après chaque podcasts ont fait encore
moins de filtres ou est ce que on
discute pas de casque on vient de
tourner avec littéralement moins de fil
que 0 notamment pas de filtre j'en ai
mal au camp justal d'imaginer comment il
n'y a pas de filtre sur cette affaire le
puits est évidemment une autre affaire
pour encourager ces deux les soeurs
eating sur toutes les applications
balade d'eau ou pas d'effet que vous sur
lesquels vous écoutez en fait notre
podcast les senneurs waiting ça fait
vraiment moche mais ça me permet de
performer mieux dans les charts qui que
les gens puissent plus voir nos podcasts
avec fait ça commente aussi fort c'est
quand même plus faux que sa commande
plus vous commentez pas beaucoup gagnent
commente il faut que autant sur youtube
autant sur balles à dos commenté
ça discute sur un style en discuterons
d'abattre des podcasts qu'on en parle
faut qu'on se parle enfin qu'il faut que
ça commente commenter cette semaine on a
reçu frédéric gagnon qui le directeur de
la chaire raoul dandurand qui est un
observatoire sur les états unis qui
projette ses états unis mais la
politique internationale
classements sont vraiment focus et soul
états unis pour parler de des élections
qui s'en vient puis du climat aux états
unis de la présidence de notre hub de
dubaï donne alors c'est vraiment un
podcast parce qu'on ne parlait que
exclusivement je demande aux politiques
américaines des élections des enjeux
importants de tout ce qui entoure ce
c'était vraiment passionnant ph chez moi
c'est un intérêt qu'on a les deux
dessous la politique américaine
puis dans la dernière semaine vraiment
bon le fait de manière décuplée c'est
vraiment se rend passionnante d'avoir ce
que le kit un professeur d'université
aussi on appris c'était incroyable
c'était super intéressant
donc j'espère que vous allez apprécier
cette fois ça vous aide à comprendre
aussi comment fonctionnent les etats
unis puissent écouter quels sont les
enjeux de la prochaine élection comme
disait frédéric tous les élections
semblent être historique aux états unis
mais celle là
d'autant plus parce que comme vous allez
entendre dans le podcast
les enjeux sont réels et sont énormes
donc bonne bonne écoute et bon podcast
mode écoute
[Musique]
dans tous les cas je pense pas qu on
vraiment quelque chose à dire là avec le
sujet d'aujourd'hui
merci d'être là premièrement tabriz et
merci de me recevoir
peux tu nous expliquer c'est quoi la
charge
raoul dandurand ouest une chaire de
recherche d'un centre de recherche qui
est basé à l'université du québec à
montréal ça a été créée en 1996 par mon
collègue et ami charles philippe de jean
philippe david qui était professeur au
département de science politique comme
moi et une chaire de recherche qui se
penche sur plein d'enjeux internationaux
mais notamment sur la politique
américaine
on a une équipe de recherche donc sur
les états unis une sur le moyen orient
et l'afrique du nord on est une équipe
de recherche aussi qui travaille
beaucoup sur les questions de
cybersécurité à les opérations de
prévention des conflits à
l'international un observatoire de
géopolitique aussi qui se penche sur les
murs les frontières en relations
internationales ali phénomène migratoire
à l'échelle internationale aussi mais là
je vous cacherais pas que notre équipe
était unie et pas mal mobiliser cette
hausse est ce comme c'est à chaque fois
qu'il ya des élections aux états unis
est ce que c'est les quatre ans les plus
bizarres de la politique américaine en
tout cas parmi ce que j'ai vécu parmi
les dix ans les parmi les années que
j'ai vécu je te dirais que c'est ccap
année assez rocambolesque des fois je
disais c'est paranormal ces étranges en
âge à 9,16 chaque fois qu'il ya une
élection aux états unis on dira ce sera
une élection historique on a
l'impression qu'elle est toujours une
affection espère eric ciotti story mais
je dirais qu'en 2016 on a été assez
étonné à devoir
dans l'autre choc gagner cette élection
là parce que c'est pas un politicien
puis se vante de soupe je pense que ça
fait partie des choses que que ses
partisans un monstre politiciens qu'ils
avaient bon il est devenu politicien
avec notamment au début il y avait pas
beaucoup d'expérience est plutôt un
homme d'affaires qui étaient là pour
montrer aux politiciens finalement qu'on
peut faire les choses autrement et sa
campagne électorale de 2007 était très
différente de ce à quoi on avait été
habitué jusque là à des mots des propos
parfois vulgaire des attaques
personnelles à n'en plus finir en
madame clinton sur le plan du
financement aussi il avait moins
d'argent qu'hillary clinton pour faire
sa campagne il se préparait pas pour les
débats des choses qu'on n'avait jamais
vu il ya gagné nous a étonnés même si
bon il y en a plusieurs qui disait il a
des chances de gagner en 2016
il y en a d'autres qui pensaient que
c'était pas possible mais bon ya gagné
puis l'homme il se présente pour un
deuxième mandat parce qu'on pense que ça
donne le 3 novembre
je me souviens très bien ton collègue
fait mon ancien étudiant a fait sa
maîtrise avec moi il était pareil dans
les séminaires à audi croyable raphaël
yens maîtrise une connaissance un croix
de la musique américaine mais il ya
toujours été un petit peu comme ça des
as mais grosse tête mais aussi mineur il
était comme ça aussi et ils se
trompaient pas souvent cet effet qui
connaît beaucoup mais effectivement il
ya là clip love
après la controverse c'était le globe à
de possibles si dans notre chambre gang
ces élections là c'est impossible qu'ils
gagnent sig eng g déni c'est juste pour
illustrer à quel point personnes
s'attendaient à city way nonce a étonné
beaucoup de gens ici on parle de raphaël
jacob si au québec
mais aux états unis il ya des gens qui
ont dit toutes sortes de choses aussi du
même genre ouais il ya dana milbank
qu'un journaliste du washington post je
pense qu'ils avaient dit si 30 gang
citerons pas du succès je vous promets
de manger cet exemplaire papier de mon
article
l'église à novembre par abc mélangisme
là une vidéo de ça on le voit la
cafétéria
en fait le coach de la cafétéria qui
fait du papil donc ça a été étonnant
mais mais je pense qu'on je pense que ce
que ça donne maintenant c'est qu'on est
un petit peu plus prudent évidemment vu
du 3 novembre
est ce que les gens ont oublié en 2016
c'est qu'il ya de bons modèles
probabilistes qui permettent de dire ben
voici les chances que le candidat gants
sont de 20% et son de 30% dans 4 up en
2016 si on regarde disons le modèle
donné dix éleveurs que vous pouvez
consulter en ligne ci sur le site five
days est le modèle donné dix éleveurs en
2016 le la veille de l'élection donner
quelque chose comme 30% chances de
victoires 3 qui quand un bon pourcentage
et c'est bon c'est quand même une chance
sur 3 ou à contrer les gens ont
simplement oublié que rien n'était sûr
en 2016 et que des fois on surestime en
fait peut-être si la capacité en fait on
surestime le c'est à dire 30 % c'est
paris si je veux dire élevé pour le même
modèle on est à deux semaines de
l'élection aujourd'hui si vous regardez
le même modèle phare feriez trempette à
12 % de chances de gagner donc lensois
qui bat et donner la bonne position mais
ça veut pas dire si c'est encore une
fois des indh tellement surpris une fois
je me dis il est prié prié qui est
certain il n'y a plus qu'une certitude
on dirait le tpiy puis j'ai l'impression
espace quoi qui cause ce mais peut-être
parce qu'il est une espèce de jeunes
apprenons aussi aussi pro de notre homme
parce que clairement dans les sondages
baden talent avance mais ça se pratique
dans l'urne gaye espèce de revirements
que la personne qui dit que dans le
sondage qu'elle est votée byden
secrètement à la envie de voter pour ce
choc 100 c'est ce qui peut causer ce
genre de revirements en 2016 c'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait c'est ça que les
gens pas vu venir je dirais une des
choses qu'on n'a pas vu venir il y avait
il y avait plus d'un des six en 2016 qui
en a cette année y avait peut-être dix
ans 15% d'indécis dans le dernier droit
de la campagne en 2016 et clinton et
trompe étaient deux candidats que les
gens détestent souvent disait tu as le
choix entre la peste et le choléra dans
l'air du temps
puis vers vers les derniers jours de
l'élection y avait beaucoup d'indécis et
puis finalement bon ulla l'histoire des
courriels de madame clinton qui
ressortit à quelques jours de l'élection
puis dans l'ue en effectivement il ya
beaucoup d'indécis qui ont dit pourquoi
pas essayer avec trempe on verra bien ce
que ça donne la différence cette année
c'est que bien trempé au pouvoir dont
les résultats donnent les gens ont eu le
temps de voir ce que ça donne car en
d'autres hommes soit on aime soit on
aime pas et il ya moins d'un des six
cette année en vue du 3 novembre en 2016
quand je disais que c'est peut-être 15%
20% par moments cette fois ci à
lapproche 3 novembre on est peut-être à
5 6% d'indécis et donc tram doit aller
chercher ce vote là parce qu'il ya à peu
près 40 2 % dans les intentions de vote
en ce moment il ya besoin de se rendre
je pense à 46 47 % pour avoir des
chances de bonnes chances de gagner
cette élection là y'a pas été capable de
le faire pour le moment il reste encore
un petit peu d'aidé 6 milliards de moins
qu'en 2016 et c'est ça qui lui rend la
tâche un petit peu plus complet
compliqué cette année géniale encore une
des choses
encore une fois cette année j'ai
l'impression que comme en 2016
on a encore le choix de 15,2 inspire un
teckel quand épreuve jambières inspirant
pour ben du monde l'irak son projet mais
si c'était propos pour trump joe biden
mais sam pas un candidat du renouveau
qui va amener de la fraîcheur qui va
amener de la gêne à ce parti là j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont arabes unis-
enders qui était qu'ils étaient capables
de soulever un peu plus lent les
patients encore là encore l'homme c'est
ce que je trouve vraiment le plus
curieux dans la politique américaine
s'est il fait des visites des vieux
bonhomme au dessus en disant qu est-ce
qui qu'est ce qui explique ce pourquoi
est ce que c'est juste parce que dans le
site
comme ça a toujours été ça puisse tout
le temps pourquoi ses pattes et il y en
avait des candidats démocrates qui
étaient plus jeunes qui étaient plus
plus vigoureux puis nulle part même même
dit même des républicains en fait oui il
ya de très très bons candidats très très
bonne candidate dans les deux parties
mais c'est sûr que cette année on a un
petit peu plus regardé ce qui se passait
du côté démocrate et y en avait des plus
jeunes
on peut penser à petit bolide j'ai déjà
le maire de sa benne en indiana ce test
un jeune politicien extrêmement
talentueux qui a autour je pense que
même pas 40 ans donc ça c'est ça
représente en partie le l'avenir de ce
parti là il y avait sinon on imite le
berkshire kamala harris qui est la
collision de joe biden les plus jeunes
ont un peu plus de difficulté à
s'imposer parce que les partis
politiques américains sont de grandes
tentes
ainsi il ya deux parties et la société
quand même assez diversifiée et pour
gagner l'investiture d'un parti pour
devenir chef d'un parti des gens il faut
il faut être capable de rassembler une
coalition électorale très très vaste et
très diversifié ça ça prend du temps et
quand les gens me disent comment ce
fait-il que les vieux bon plus de
facilité ben c'est que le temps de le
rue ce temps là si vous regardez durban
donne moi je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est pas nécessairement le candidat
démocrate le plus le plus charismatique
mois puis disons le plus dynamique bon
il ya 77 ans n'ont pas se cacher c'est
très difficile de faire campagne aux
états unis ça dure longtemps c'est
éreintant mais il a été vice président
barack obama était sénateur pendant des
dizaines d'années
il ya eu le temps de bâtir cette
coalition électorale qui lui a permis de
gagner l'investiture du parti démocrate
est ce que fait la différence entre
autres c'est que bart hayden avait
beaucoup d'appui auprès des électeurs
afro-américain des électrices afro
américaine
donc si vous vous souvenez la course la
course à la chefferie démocrate de la
course à l'investiture démocrate
by dane a commencé à gagner dans le sud
des états unis notamment quand il a
gagné la primaire la caroline du sud où
là il se retrouve en présence de sa le
super tuesday
c'était juste avant le super tuesday une
primaire en caroline du sud ça a été le
game challenger il ya gagné là pourquoi
il le disait depuis le début quand on
bosse on va se retrouver dans des états
où il ya beaucoup d'électeurs
afro-américains je vais me mettre à
gagner et c'est ça que c'est ça qui a
fait la différence je dirais leur un des
facteurs en tout cas donc pitbull hodges
j'en reviens à lui a pas eu le temps
nécessairement de bâtir ses appuis la
même chose pour bernice enders qui avait
pas beaucoup d'appui auprès des
électeurs afro-américains plus âgées les
jeunes afro américaine les mails et mais
quand même
mais c'est ça je suis vraiment une
affaire de coalition départ et je pense
que cette année aussi les démocrates ont
décidé d'aller de l'avant avec une
candidature save moi c'est moi je disais
souvent c'est pas moi qui ai inventé ça
une journaliste de cnn qui disait byden
c'est le candidat bouillon de poulet le
plus de bases qui ont assuré ne pas
faire paraître au monde
le comfort food a tramp a été pour les
démocrates une grosse grippe d'a4
quelque chose de réconfortant brasse
potro est ce que est ce que contre en
2016 je reviens aux élections 2016 avec
larry clinton est ce que contre un
candidat plus bouillon de poulet jaune
peut regagner en 2016
c'est une bonne question mais c'est vrai
qu'il a réclamée n'était pas très ce
sont vraiment deux élections différence
jeudi en 2016 qui a peut être nui à
madame clinton ce qu'elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas très populaire personnellement
dans ce pays il dit mais j'en reviens ce
que je disais tantôt c'est la coved 19
ou la peste bubonique et elle et elle
n'était pas très populaire
personnellement parce que les clinton
les clinton ont repassé les clinton
la famille clinton est très détesté dans
l'est dans les milieux républicains aux
états unis il ya des gens qui pour
toutes sortes de raisons a l'impression
qu'elle n'est pas
enfin ne pourrait pas honnête parce que
bon dans dans l'histoire de cette
famille clinton
elle a pris des décisions un moment
donné qui visait surtout à maximiser les
chances de bill clinton de gagner une
élection au poste de gouverneur en
arkansas une élection à la
présidentielle
en 1992 on fait référence notamment aux
affaires extra-conjugales de bill
clinton hillary qui dit auprès de son
mari bon je lui pardonne et tout ça il
ya des gens ça ça a donné l'impression à
bien des gens qu'ils sont un peu en fait
qu'ils sont là surtout pour le pouvoir
tous des partenaires politiques qui
donnent un vrai qu'au bleu sort et ce
qui est venu à l'ancienneté dans 2016
c'est qu'au fond il ya eu une
intervention russe dans l'élection elle
et des hackers russes ont mis la main
sur des courriels du parti démocrate qui
ont révélé notamment qu'elle avait des
positions différentes par public et en
privé sur des questions très importantes
pour les électeurs notamment toute cette
affaire des accords de commerce
défavorables aux travailleurs américains
le partenariat transpacifique et tout ça
donc est ce qu'un candidat plus bouillon
de poulet aurait pu permettre de gagner
en 2007 chaussures parce que le contexte
est différent il y à un moment donné si
l'usure du pouvoir aussi qu'il reste
neuf et il ya des gens qui après huit
années de présidence obama de présidence
démocrate avait juste envie d'autre
chose
est ce que le fait
qu'elle était une femme aurait pas pu
jouer aussi ce que les états unis sont
prêts à avoir une présidence c'est une
excellente question je pense que oui
mais je me demande s'il était prêt et
elle était prête à élire sept 7 femmes
sur cette femme là madame clinton
mais sinon il ya toute une littérature
scientifique on peut penser aux travaux
d'eric fort qu'il y en a d'autres
qualités dès demain aussi qui démontre
que c'est plus difficile évidemment pour
les pros les femmes de percer dans ces
milieux là pour toutes sortes de raisons
il ya encore des sites et des
stéréotypes de genre associée à la
fonction présidentielle il ya des gens
qui ont l'impression que ça prend un
homme dans sa peau si de là et
d'ailleurs quand linton a fait campagne
en 2008 notamment
elle était entourée parce que bon elle
fait campagne deux fois pour la
présidentielle 2008 et 2016 et en 2008
elle s'est entourée de conseillers homme
qui lui disait justement puisque ce que
tu disais on n'est pas sûr que la
société américaine est prête à élire une
femme par contre si tu te comportes
madame clinton un peu plus comme un
homme tu as peut-être plus de chances de
gagner
c'est pour ça qu'elle avait fait une
campagne où il disait à knb de commander
in chief j'ai de l'expérience en matière
de sécurité nationale peut mener des
guerres ce type de campagne électorale
mais les mentalités évoluent sauf que
c'est quand même encore plus difficile
je dirais pour les femmes en politique
aux états unis et il ya plusieurs
chercheur à la chaire qui travaille là
dessus et elisabeth vallet notamment que
vous connaissez peut-être andréanne
bissonnette véronique pronovost il y en
a d'autres
ok puis à mettons qu'on se ramène aux
quatre dernières années puis de deux
présidences de notre homme puis qu'on
essaie de voir un petit peu
qu'est ce que s'est passé de tous les
côtés c'est qu'est ce qui a été fait
qu'est ce qui a été pas fait qu
évidemment eu là que vides que tout
chambouler ça mais on a tendance à
agacer oublier les trois derrière les
trois premières années de son mandat le
parce qu'elle en ce moment ce n'est que
ce qu'on voit ce n'est que de ça qu'on
parle mais esker au final de notre amour
était un bon président pour les états
unis au delà
ce qu'on voit sur twitter peek du
personnage
ses partisans sont très content de ce
qu'il a fait d'ailleurs des fois je
montrais ça à mes étudiants à l'uqam la
pierre mais regagne trempette et a à peu
près à 42 pour cent d'appuis en octobre
en octobre 2016 à quelques semaines de
l'élection
on est à quelques semaines de l'élection
de 2000 veille et encore à 42 pour cent
d'appuis donc les gens qui l'aiment lem
pauvres est d'ailleurs trump avait dit
en 2016 à coach ou de pi pompes funèbres
new jeu pour être tiré sur des gens sur
fifth avenue à new york puis mes
partisans continueraient puis bon quand
on est un peu critique de tron pour
trouve ça étonnant parce qu'on le voit à
libon dit mais comment ça se fait que
les gens continuent à l'appui il ya deux
trois choses qui a fait qu'ils plaisent
beaucoup à ses partisans
la nomination de juges conservateurs
dans les cours fédérales et à la cour
suprême très important c'est un coup de
juger plus d'une centaine de juges qui
ont pointé à la cour suprême ainsi
réussi à garantir la nomination d'une
majorité 6 6 3 ce matin on passe à 6,3 à
la cour suprême ces dénominations
lifetime à la cour suprême c'est ces
dénominations la vie sexuelle c'est que
ça s'en va pas destitué
est ce que c'est possible déçu je
vérifie dans mon manuel ils sont nommés
à vie et donc ça a un effet considérable
sur la vie politique américaine qui on
les nomme jeunes pour s'assurer qu'ils
soient le plus longtemps possible
non donc dans la cinquantaine madame
ginsburg est décédé et a récemment la
juge qui est remplacé par monsieur de
chambre en ce moment elle a été là
pendant plusieurs décennies donc ça a un
effet considérable sur la suite des
choses parce que la cour suprême a ce
pouvoir
elle peut invalider en fait les
décisions du président et loi du congrès
qui ne ferait pas les affaires de
certains groupes pour cent de la société
américaine
la cour suprême peut pas dire ok
aujourd'hui je me on évalue de telles
décisions du président mais elle peut
être saisie par des des acteurs
politiques américains de certaines
causes sur lesquels elle se penche et
essayer
cision finalement peuvent mené à
l'invalidation de certaines lois qu'on
pense par exemple à la réforme
d'assurance santé d'obama de barack
obama ça pourrait être un dangereux ça
au cours des prochaines semaines après
l'élection la cour suprême pourrait être
appelé à se pencher là dessus et
invalidé une partie de la réforme de
barack obama donc ça ça a des
conséquences considérables
il ya des gens aussi qui ont qui ont
comparé que la cour suprême revienne sur
la décision rovi wade de 1973 c'est une
décision qui interdisait aux états
d'interdire l'avortement
donc ça c'est une des grandes réussites
de trame aux yeux de ses partisans il a
changé le visage des cours fédérales et
de la cour suprême
une autre grande réussite de trump selon
ses partisans c'est la reine la
renégociation de certains accords de
commerce et la same l'accord de commerce
entre le canada les états unis et le
mexique
c'est un accord de commerce qui est très
populaire aux états unis à peu près 80%
des américains qui eux mêmes des
démocrates qui sont très satisfaits de
ce que trump a fait sur ce dossier là il
a entre autres permis aux fermiers du
wes cantine d'avoir un meilleur accès au
marché canadien pour leurs produits
il ya une autre réussite de trompes aux
yeux de ses partisans qui est qui et la
réduction des impôts la réduction des
impôts sa réforme fiscale de 2017
il a réduit les impôts de à peu près
tout le monde aux états unis mais
surtout des des gens les plus fortunés
des entreprises les impôts sur les gains
en capital aussi c'est à dire les gens
qui ont des investissements en bourse
non je dirais que ça ce sont trois
grandes réussites sinon il ya des choses
qui peuvent faire construire son mur
entre les etats-unis et le mexique le
mexique voulait pas payer pour le mur
mais aux états unis lé congrès est très
puissant et c'est le bon il ya la maison
blanche il ya le congrès la cour suprême
sur sont les trois institutions
fédérales et le congrès qui est la
législature fédérale l'équivalent de 10
ont dû du parlement à ottawa pour nous
mais le congrès très très indépendant de
la maison blanche très autonome
rapport à la maison blanche ait fait pas
toujours ce que le président veut et le
congrès adopte les lois fédérales et les
budgets fédéraux et pour le mur
américano-mexicain ben le congrès a
juste dit non vous aurez pas les fonds
pour le faire tremper ici retournez
essayer de trouver des fonds ailleurs
des petits fonds de tiroir dans des
départements mais il n'y a pas pu faire
ce qu'ils voulaient dans ce dossier
notamment y avait une clôture de qom 150
km pilote c'est ça à peu pressés et mais
évidemment évidemment campagne
électorale il dit ben on a réussi on a
commencé puis on va continuer ça
d'ailleurs sa plateforme électorale de
2020 c'est celle de 2016 poursuite de
cette promesse l'oeuvre de dire on va
faire un mur puis le mexique va payer
pour le mur c'est une promesse
impossible à tenir
quand m comme en vue du sulfate est
convenu de rendre possible le temps où
elle est ce qu'on retient avec tram
c'est que ça c'est pas grave c'est qu'il
ya tout un dieu tout un aspect théâtral
qui est liée à la faire et il pas le
premier à faire ça tous les candidats
présidentiels promettent la lune alors
qu'on sait très bien que le système
politique américaine ne permet pas de
faire ça donne en fait des promesses en
ce moment puis quand les gens me
demandent où est quels sont les
programmes de baden et rome
je les présente les programmes mais j'ai
une petite arrière pensée ici qui me dit
ben ça donne pas grand-chose de
présenter ça dans le détail à ce moment
ci parce qu'il va falloir voir quel est
l'état des forces politiques au congrès
notamment après l'élection de savoir
qu'est-ce qui va pas c'est qu'elle n'y
passera pas mais j'en reviens à 30
rempiler dans tantôt je le disais c'est
un novice en politique en arrivant la
maison blanche mais il est très bon en
communication très bon en communication
très bons pour trouver la petite phrase
qui accroche qui d'ailleurs et
communique beaucoup sur twitter à
quelques caractères bon après les gens
peut-être après quatre ans on veut peu
tanné d'eau se fatigue du double fatigue
du tweet mai mais il a le sens de la
formule
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas des
fondations spectacle sens du spectacle
aussi littéralement il vient du monde de
la télé réalité aussi le type du
spectacle donc ici c'était pas la
première fois qu'il y avait
à avoir un tag line peut être as brenda
se mettre comme ça oui c'est tout à fait
vrai le mets en taule disait il ya une
fatigue peut-être après quatre ans parce
que évidemment le problème avec ça c'est
quand tu promet la lune tous les jours
pendant quatre ans que les résultats ne
sont pas au rendez vous un moment donné
les gens disent ok on connaît la chanson
les traits quatre ans il ya deux trois
réalisations il ya bien des choses qu'il
n'a pas pu faire non plus il ya quand
même tenu ses promesses certaine manière
les gens qui ont voté pour lui une
impression t après sopi on peut juger
ses promesses le étaient bonnes montées
la ville de la direction est bonne ou
mauvaise mais n'empêche que sur les
points qu'on a nommé les les impôts les
traiter il a tenu ses promesses sur un
thé avec amour lui aussi sa sa campagne
en 2016 sur le slogan green de soins
plus puis au final y était aussi
corrompu toutes les autres fait
probablement que sa base électorale
j'imagine qui en a qui ont vu ça aussi
le qui ont voté pour lui pour le jane de
soins bio qui en sort de cette espèce de
corruption le puits qui ont été déçus de
la façon que ça a été fait
oui mais encore là ses partisans sont
convaincus qu'il est malgré toutes les
histoires dont on entend parler encore
moins pire que les politiciens de
carrière
d'ailleurs en ce moment on entend encore
parler d'histoire de corruption parce
que la nouvelle la nouvelle histoire sur
laquelle troupe met l'accent ce sont des
en fait les des courriels de rentrer
byden fils de joe biden qui aurait selon
le récit de tromper de ses partisans
profité du fait que joe banner était
vice président durant obama pour avoir
accès à des postes super important en
ukraine notamment à des contrats en
chine et tout ça et mais c'est drôle les
partisans de troy oublie que ses propres
enfants ont aussi profité du fait qu'ils
résident depuis quatre ans qu'il est
même lui profiter du sud gros double
standard c'est ça mais mais encore
souvent jeudi j'ai pas si vous regardez
leurs acquis si vous aimez le rock et
moi je regarde couleurs et tout ça j'ai
joué à arqués quand j'étais jeune
puis quand on était petits nous aurons
qu'il y avait une rivalité entre les
canadiens puis une heure dix au quai
tu connais pour les nordiques c'était
juste impossible de dire quoi que ce
soit de bon à propos des canadiens
restent verse à la politique américaine
est devenue un petit peu comme ça c'est
peut-être pas la mer analogique soit
mais est ce sport et c'est devenu une
affaire presque sportive émotive
quand tu aimes pas l'autre équipe qui va
toujours trouver le moyen de dire que
l'autre équipe a triché ou l'autre
équipe est pire que la tienne et on est
un peu là dedans et bonsoir disons dans
ce qu'on fait il ya toute une
littérature là dessus sur la
polarisation de la société anonyme qui
est devenu hyper polarisation et il ya
même des gens qui parlent maintenant de
trail blazers c'est à dire un peu ce que
je dis on n'est même plus dans la
logique de l'argumentation
on est plutôt dans la dans la querelle
identitaire cité de l'autre partie je
veux rien savoir de toi et vice versa
fait même des données de sondage qui
démontre qu'il ya de moins en moins de 2
par an de moins en moins de parents qui
acceptent que leurs enfants épouses
quelqu'un du parti adverse bien donc on
en est là donc c'est générationnel en
plus c'est dans les familles c'était une
famille démocrate pitt et démocrates
d'une famille républicaine quitté
républicaine fou c'est ça c'est ça et et
avant il y avait ça n'a pas toujours été
comme ça mais avant il y avait il y
avait une possibilité de dialogue dans
les années 60 70
mais depuis les années 90 cette histoire
est devenue une histoire très triste
dans le fond parce que les membres des
deux partis ne sont plus capable de
s'adresser la parole alors que le
système politique américain est fait de
telle manière à ce que les compromis
soit nécessaire pour que les choses
progressent
longuet et c'est pour ça que bon quand
les gens disent qu'est ce que ben laden
va être capable de faire j'ai ça dépend
de la manière dont les républicains au
congrès vont se comporter à son égard et
même si les démocrates sont majoritaires
au sein des deux chambres du congrès il
ya encore des règles propres à cette
institution la au sénat des états unis
la chambre haute du congrès qui fait que
la minorité peut quand même encore
empêcher le parti au pouvoir d'aller de
l'avant avec ses projets donc t'as pas
le choix de faire des compromis ce point
un système qui comme le système canadien
où monsieur trudeau en situation de
gouvernement majoritaire peu oui
lorsqu'il veut presque du dialogue c'est
sûr mais il peut aller
plus facilement de l'avant avec ses
projets quel président des états unis
inquiets à washington je partis qui
présentent états unis espèce de pouvoir
ce qui me semble qu'il ya de l'argent
qui rentre et puis beaucoup d'autres
exécutif qui ont été tes de loi qui
s'est décrite du président pi d'attitude
ça passe puis c'est ça il ya le décret
présidentiel tu fait très bien de le
mentionner ça c'est d'un outil qui est
apparu avec le temps et qui permet au
président oui de de prendre certaines
décisions relatives à la manière dont
son administration fonctionnent les
départements et tout ça mais je te donne
un exemple trump a annoncé par décret
qui voulaient construire son mur entre
les etats-unis et le mexique mais il
faut des fonds pour construire le mur il
adopte les budgets le congrès donc les
décrets souvent sont des annonces mais
il faut autre chose une autre décision
d'une autre institution le congrès
souvent pour que ces décrets là
deviennent effectifs ouais vraiment est
vraiment de l'impact est bon il ya eu
aussi le décret anti entier migration le
trompe annoncé qu'ils fermaient les
frontières les frontières aux
ressortissants de plusieurs pays où on
de plusieurs pays du moyen-orient et
tout ça qui est intégrée littéralement
racisme on ferme les frontières aux
musulmans c'est si ce qui est critique
de trempe on dit évidemment puis ça a
été très très contreversé way est encore
là c'est un système de croiser
contrepoids et les cours
il ya des cours à ce moment là qu'ils
ont dit ce décret la ne respecte pas la
constitution des états unis dont connu
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
qu'il ya une limite à ce que le
président peut faire par décret aussi
puis au début de sa présidence a amené
je me rappelle tendance
dans une conférence de presse puis il
disait que son pouvoir était absolut ce
que les plaques qui joue l'été my world
et absolute
c'est juste parce que eh bien en fait
j'imagine que ce cccc le playboy de
donald trump de fer des stands comme ça
sans être factcheck et qui vont qui vont
convaincre son base mais est ce que ça
c'était juste que ils connaissaient mal
le système où c'était vraiment ici sur
la même position que pris en
connaissance de cause devant jouer à
dire sur même si c'est pas réellement
que m trempez quelqu'un qui depuis le
début de sa présidence et s'est étiré
l'élastique l'année moquera samir qui
annonce possible
il essaie d'étendre le plus possible les
pouvoirs du président encore une fois il
n'est pas le premier à faire ça w bush a
fait ça après le 11 septembre il y en a
d'autres mais 30 étire l'élastique étire
l'élastique
il a souvent dit de ce système que c'est
un système archaïque que c'est un
système qui n'est pas bon pour le peuple
américain
ce qui est en train de dire ce qu'ils
aimeraient avoir encore plus de pouvoirs
à type de prise à titre de président
parce que oui c'est un peu frustrant tu
te faire dire non par le congrès mais le
système fonctionne comme ça donc quand
ils disent est en train de dire qu'ils
aimeraient gouverner un pays dont le
système est différent on sait qu'il ya
une certaine admiration pour les leaders
autoritaire d'ailleurs j'aimerais
gouverner dans ce type de pays là
pourquoi parce que sont son parcours
csii a été à la tête d'entreprises qui
portait son nom et où il était haut de
la hiérarchie
la seule personne qui prennent qui peut
prendre toutes les décisions exactement
je décide et dans son livre ii des
années 90 à 9,2 diront un livre à lille
super important je pense pour comprendre
fait qu'elle agisse abyss cologie les
termes d'affaires à ce moment à l'up ça
a été coécrit par tour nichoirs ce
livre-là et tony choisi dit le trump que
je décris dans ce livre là ne correspond
pas du tout à la réalité
gg roman c'est un petit peu trop
présente trente sous son meilleur jour
un homme d'affaires capable de faire de
bons deals et ça m'est tombé choisi
trompe pas tellement aimé le trempe que
je décris là-dedans qu'après ça et
essayer de devenir le tram dont je parle
dans libre à vous lire et ça c'est
intéressant mais sega le 4 4 le regarda
les quatre gars et speedy ship ici aussi
l'information qui qui vient jusqu'à nous
soumettre les réseaux sociaux au travers
les médias à travers twitter fin de la
de quelqu'un complètement erratiques le
tai chi qui pourrait m'en direction qui
veut dire quelque chose peut être son
contraire lendemain impliqué mais est-ce
que y est aussi ce qui est ce qui s qui
sait ce qui fait ce qui est un contrôle
de son image puis tout est calculé
picard en réalité sous tous ceux y
sondages indiquent qu'ils posent piller
serbie puis tout seul il sert finalement
sa direction de sa cause où il fait
vraiment n'importe quoi mais j'en
reviens olive olive 10h09 de dire il ya
un passage là dedans qui est un qui est
assez intéressant qui nous permet de
comprendre un peu comme un gouvernent
depuis qu'il est à la maison blanche il
ya quelques passages importants
il ya un passage où il dit quand
j'arrive au bureau le matin j'ai pas
trop de plein air dont ceux dont kerry
edit je n'arrive pas que ma mallette au
bureau de méthyle aussi tout près 10 et
j'arrive au bureau je vois ce qui se
présente à moi et je fais ma journée en
fonction de ce donc un peu
d'improvisation pas mal d'improvisation
à grant hill et hommes d'affaires il se
fit beaucoup à son instinct c'est à dire
ben s'y attellent problème si je
confronte ait un tel problème ce jour là
bas
je vais régler centre de foires et puis
je vais ce sera ça ma journée
première chose donc je pense à nous en
apprend pas mal sur la manière dont ils
gouvernent parce que le lundi une
déclaration x le mardi à une déclaration
contraire il est un peu comme ça l'autre
chose qu'il dit dans son livre diotte de
dios et j'écoute mes conseillers mais
pas trop et j'ai souvent l'impression
que je comprends mieux ce qui se passe
que me conseillez regarder ce qu'il fait
en lien claque au vent il l'a dit encore
à son réalise du nevada ya quelques
jours et dib hayden vais écouter les
scientifiques mois moi je les écoute
très peu scientifique mais si je les
écoutais jusqu'au bout tout notre pays
seraient fermées en ce moment pensera en
récession il a souvent dit le contraire
mais le mahb a évidemment ça c'est
l'argument de ces critiques
parce que oui il ya eu pire il ya bien
des gens qui le disent il ya eu de
l'improvisation dans l'est dans les
premiers mois de la pandémie
oui c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
notamment bob audois ce journaliste très
très que vous connaissez réputé qui a
dit ben et 30 me disais à moi lors de
nos entretiens qui trouvaient que le
virus était dangereusement public qui
disaient le contraire en janvier qu'ils
s l exacte du début j'allais commencer
son livre le gie lui peut-être une
centaine de pages phi phi d'utiliser le
prologue traite de ce justement à quel
point finalement à juin janvier appelle
bourbourg depuis elle se faire soigner
est vraiment dangereux pu vraiment
mortel puis c'est pas drôle de nolan
appui ben inquiet après celle là dans le
public c'est à ces zones ne suffisait
pas pire qu'une grippe n'a l'anapi juste
parce qu'il voulait en guillemets peau
creed de paniquer mais finalement la 4
220 mille personnes qui marathon pays et
la panique le titre home je pense est
très préoccupés par l'économie
je pense qu'il ya toujours un peu sans
appel les indices boursiers le taux de
chômage est très important pour lui
depuis le début de sa présidence et j'ai
l'impression c'est vraiment une
hypothèse je n'ai pas vérifié ça que je
me suis pas entretenu avec 30 puis
humaine chum entretenait avec lui il me
le dirait probablement pas mais on a
l'impression qu'au début de la pandémie
c'est pas mal ça qu'il est c'est à dire
si les gens paniquent
si l'économie ferme si on ferme nos
entreprises et tout ça ça va avoir un
effet considérable sur les indicateurs
qui m'intéresse moi
le taux de chômage ligne au même avant
le début de la pandémie historiquement
bol -2 4%
il avait sa place à près de 15 % en
avril ça c'est que l'heure pour un
président qui à la proche d'une
réélection veut faire campagne sur son
bilan économique
donc je pense qu'il a essayé de trouver
un équilibre entre on va lutter contre
le virus sans faire paniquer les gens
pour pas que l'économie perd des plumes
mais finalement c'est son glaive il ne
s'agit plus de plus de 215 milles morts
mais je pense qu'ils je pense qu'ils
souhaitent
il souhaite probablement que le virus
soit pas aussi grave qu'il ait été
finalement qui aiment mandy tu réalises
que non c'est très grave pour une
conférence de presse qu'il donne je sais
à la mi mars à peu près au moment où il
parla audouard d'eau si tu vas qui
semble y avoir un changement dans son
esprit le c'est là où il ya la
conférence de presse puis il dit à
porter un masque fait attention
distanciation physique puis il avoue à
ce moment là dans la conférence de
presse que l'économie se dirige
peut-être vers une récession c'est comme
s'il y avait un aveu de sa part que why
essayer de sauver l'économie mais
finalement ce sera pas possible donc
maintenant on est peut-être nous de
faire un peu plus attention au virus et
oui il ya jongler que des vies humaines
et ça lui nuit en ce moment à vue de sa
réélection
c'est l'enjeu le coronavirus et l'enjeu
le plus important aux yeux des électeurs
25% des électeurs disent que c'est
l'enjeu le plus important à leurs yeux
les connais mills et 10%
les gens pensent que c'est très
important à leurs yeux l'économie c'est
tellement ça existe pole dance est un
concept c'est un concept qu'on a créé
c'est un concept qui qui témoin mettons
la thune parle d'économie et puis je me
dis à gaz que c'est mieux d'avoir un
pays qui va bien économiquement mais
concrètement si rien pour moi mais de
qom ne pas pouvoir voir mon grand père
pendant deux ans dans les derniers 25 et
15 ans de sa vie ben ça c'est concrètes
sa santé la santé c'est concret loin
exact
ce que c'est qu'un camp qu'il ya cette
espèce de débat sur l'économie je
comprends que l'économie est dans un
système comme lequel on est c'est super
important pour que tout fonctionne mais
on dirait que c'est deux choses qui sont
pas du deux poids deux mesures le
complètement way puis c'est la ccc la
réflexion de beaucoup de gens aux états
unis en ce moment si tu regardes les
sondages d'opinion le genre bien ce que
je disais tantôt sur un an
c'est l'enjeu le plus important pour 25
% des américains et quand on regarde
certaines données de sondage on voit que
près de 60% des américains qui disent
que trump a mal géré ce dossier
mais sinon il ya quand même des gens aux
états unis qui disent que on en a trop
fait pour lutter contre le virus et
qu'on a on a sacré l'économie dans dalo
pis il ya des gens qui se lancent en
affaires
des petites entreprises de nouvelles
entreprises juste avant que la pandémie
commence pour nous des balles au québec
aussi et qui bon on investit 1 l'argent
qu'ils avaient accumulé pendant toute
une vie dans une entreprise que tu lance
maintenant un an avant le début de la
pandémie venait tout ferme tu perds tout
donc c'est je pense ce sont des gens qui
dirait aussi que la santé est importante
bien sûr mais mais mais il ya quand même
plusieurs années de vie perdues aussi
sur le plan économique donc est une
chose qu'il faut retenir aussi à propos
de cette société là et c'est mon ancien
prof louis balthazar qui le désire s il
était ici culturellement aussi c'est une
société qui est un peu plus allergiques
aux interventions de l'état dans la vie
des gens que dans d'autres sociétés
comparables
au québec on a ce débat là aussi mais
aux états unis les mouvements team anti
masques ont émergé beaucoup plus tôt
qu'au québec parce que bon c'est un peu
la même histoire sur le débat sur les
sur le débat sur les armes à feu
on veut pas que layton nous disent quoi
faire et tom joue là dessus quand il dit
le maersk
c'est la responsabilité individuelle
souffler le porte et portela mais on
vous oublie jeux repas le porter si vous
avez l'impression que c'est pas
obligatoire pour vous et
et donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
continué à appuyer trump parce que ils
mettaient l'accent là dessus notamment
sur la liberté du tueur la liberté on
exagère paul gouvernement vous dira
pourquoi faire le gouvernement vous dira
pas de rester à la maison a faites le si
vous pensez que c'est bon pour votre
santé m'ont vous obligera pas le faire
je ne peux n'y avait plus rien changé à
son plein mais juste dans sa
communication conscientiser donner la
bonne information des rouges en fait
attention ceux des risques et dangers
russe qui savait qui était qui et
aiderait pitié ça aurait probablement
juste ce fait une bonne différence c'est
que les gens soient vraiment au courant
de la sévérité ce virus le ok j'en fais
plus attention que plus de gens qui
mettent les marques et plus de gens qui
prennent des précautions jeu son art
éviter des morts oui et j'ai pas
l'impression qui va changer de discours
baillargé on a eu la preuve récemment
qui changera pas disponibles et puis y
revient midi les sépales virus m
bousbecque verrièle ce qui s'y passait
c'est drôle les contradictions dans le
discours parce que y'a personne qui peut
se faire soigner comme il s'est fait
soigner des traitements présidentielle
je m'excuse partie ce vendredi je pense
que vendredi pas abordé marine one way
vue des moeurs
les huit meilleurs docteurs la place qui
s'occupe de lui tout le temps les
meilleurs traitements évidemment ça
coûte cher l'aï dit moi je vous promets
une chose si je suis réélu vous aurez ce
traitement le gratuitement mais là la
preuve reste à faire mais je suis ça
contre ce il utilise sa présidence et se
bat contre ses deux frères obamacare
c'est ouais il peut pas promettre sabrer
le tpiy lui même je parle lui même le
dit lundi j'ai eu le meilleur traitement
l'anapi peu de monde car axé sur 15 mois
on va entendre
mais si une absurdité derrière tout ça
je pense que je pense qu'elle est
parallèle à faire avec
avec l'élection de 1981 entre règle
unique école et carter ronald reagan et
et jimmy carter ce que trump est en
train de faire en disant tout ça c'est
que parmi les deux candidats il y en a
un qui est plus homme que l'eau ont été
plus masculin que l'autre qui est plus
tough que l'eau qui est plus il le dit
on souvent quand il parle des gens et 10
izotov mère ni pardon quelqu'un dans
folie 10 tough gars musclés email
il met beaucoup l'accent là-dessus en
essayant de convaincre les américains
que byden est un peu efféminé qui faible
pas d'énergie et en 1981 ce lipide dubaï
donne en 1980 avait un peu la même
dynamique quand reagan et carter car
père s'excusait durant sa présidence
d'avoir pris les mauvaises décisions
certains moments et reagan puis bon
c'est à après le vietnam la société
américaine passer un mauvais quart
d'heure parce qu'on se demandait si si
on est encore une super puissance est
tout sourire guen arrivent en 1981 en
disant notamment c'est assez on a le
meilleur pays au monde
on peut gagner la compétition militaires
conclus rss on va relancer les dépenses
militaires à fond de train
mais bon toute une série de films aussi
des années 80 qui a qui met l'accent sur
ces thèmes-là la syrie brembo la série
ouaki et je pense que tom joue un peu
là-dessus pile utilise le fait qu'il ce
que fait aussi tousser réinvestir le
treut massivement dans le militaire
exact c'est comme si ce moment mon armée
est plus grosse que la sienne cc on joue
les durs puis il joue les durs dans son
rapport au virus
ok on on s'enferme repas dans nos
maisons
on
dire on se fera pas dire quoi faire par
le gouvernement by day napoli bon pas
les bonnes les bonnes politiques parce
qu'en fait si on et off on est capable
de combattre ce virus là mais mais en
fait ça marche pas quand tu regardes la
manière dont la société fonctionne ya
des gens qui ont même pas un moyen de se
faire soigner c'est facile d'être tough
qui combattent un virus cela revient ce
que je disais tantôt quand les meilleurs
docteurs autour de toi puis il régler ça
rapidement mais personne n'a pas en lui
peut-être qu'ils quelques autres
personnes qui ont cette chance là mais
aussi des communications c'était flou
parce que certaines personnes qui
disaient il va très bien et en bonne
santé dans la nappe qui avait d'autres
personnalités qui ont liquidé une
formation comme de quoi y est vraiment
mal en point puis ça va pas ça va aussi
bien que celles effectuées après so on
en face qu'on sait jamais quoi croire
avec lui on s'étonnait qu'est ce qui est
vrai
qu'est-ce qu'il est peu mais je pense
que si vrai que ça peut paraître
contradictoire sa façon de gérer les
relations publiques puis sa
communication ni foi ils passent d'un
message à l'autre jour au lendemain mais
moi je pense qu'une logique derrière ce
nous déstabiliser occuper l'espace
médiatique avec des annonces à n'en plus
finir me regarde et je veux dire quand
ils étaient 45 minutes coupable donald
trump exact ne sais pas le seul candidat
de sélection le exact on n'a même pas
parlé de dubaï danois fin mai mais 36 et
ça a toujours été ça des déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce dit pourquoi pour
occuper l'espace médiatique pour attirer
l'attention
puis les médias c'est drôle les médias
disaient on est tombé dans le panneau en
2016 on a trop parlé de lui parce qu'en
publicité gratuite ça a été chiffré le
sais j'ai pas les chiffres avec moi mais
vous pourrez trouver les tables ou là
souvent on dit en 2016 y a moins dépensé
qu'hillary clinton pour des publicités
télévisées il n'y avait pas besoin
et c'est un peu ce qui se passe en ce
moment au si et quand il ya eu cette
confusion là sur son état de santé
moi je parle ce n'est peut-être pas
aussi fin que seul est aussi programmé
que ça mais je pense qu'il est un peu de
soi parce qu'on attendait quoi on
attendait la prochaine annonce du
médecin est ce qu'elle est bien a
finalement il va pas bien là les gens
parlaient pendant 24 heures de son état
de santé
si marquez qui est ce que peines va
prendre le pouvoir est ce que pendant ce
temps alors on part de rien donc
et il ya besoin d'être visible pour le
meilleur et pour le pire puis c'est un
besoin personnel aussi il ya besoin
d'être visible il ya besoin d'attention
il ya besoin de ça besoin d'amour sega
le britrail énormément boyer
probablement un petit peu je parle pas
d'amour charnel je parle d'amour il ya
besoin d'être admiré adoré oui ça a
toujours été ça quand il était un homme
d'affaires aussi les annonces quand il
était un homme d'affaires ressembler aux
annonces qui qui qui lance en ce moment
comme président quand il nous dit
j'aurais le plus gros casinos de
l'histoire de fête de l'humanité mais au
moins de l'histoire du pays
le taj mahal finalement c'est un flop
monumental mais je passe le taj mahal un
flop monumental mais c'est pas si grave
que ça c'est tout le build up
publicitaire qui vient avec la non ce
qui permet aux non trom de circuler plus
possible dans société puis finalement
c'est pas le taj mahal qui comptent dans
leur empire tram c'est le nom 36 l'ont
si ces zonages on parlait du cycle
médiatique tantôt puis des informations
conflictuelle qu'on reçoit de tous les
côtés je veux avant ton opinion sur le
traitement médiatique aux états unis
parce que clairement de cnn et fox news
qui sont des chaînes complètement
séparée comblement partisante moi
mettons que je veux essayer d'avoir les
infos les plus neutre possible ont trait
à toutes les fois où ce que j'ai parlé à
des gens qui étaient plus brutt rome que
j'essaie d'amener 1.1 que j'avais
entendu dans une station ou de danse
d'agen dans un média quelle que soit la
réponse est tout le temps
genre que j'ai lu dans le new york times
j'ai déjà entendu aux délits routiers
des trucs comme ça c'est tout le temps
ouah mais on sait ben ouais c'est sûr
qu'ils vont dire se met au dessus
il ya eu un consensus sur un sur une
source d'information neutre qui a pas de
danger de se faire dire non à ses
partisans
lorsque tu es le new york times les
qui est contre dans notre ample
grandement fait ya dessus ça existe uc
est un média qui est comme notre piquet
les deux parties acceptent comme étant
des sources d'information neutre
c'est de plus en plus difficile c'est de
plus en plus difficile ap le paysage
médiatique américain de plus en plus
polarisé un peu à l'image de de ce qu'on
observe au sein des institutions
politiques et au sein de la société
aussi tout à l'heure quand je disais bon
c'est un enfant démocrates acceptent de
moins en moins qui épouse un républicain
et vice versa je dirais que c'est de
plus en plus difficile mais c'est
individuellement qu'on a la
responsabilité de s'exposer à une
diversité de sources
je sais que c'est pas c'est de moins en
moins facile je sais pas si vous avez
regardé le documentaire de sochaux
d'éléments qui est disponible sur
netflix en ce moment ces petits anges
elles sont belles femmes et puis moi je
suis sur les médias sociaux aussi
jeanjean avec ma gagne à la charge jeudi
à bayonne ça va bien puis finalement je
leur rappelle oubliez pas qu on est dans
notre bulle aussi ya juste des puits moi
ah bon gsm exposés à toutes sortes
d'affaires donc je vois des choses qui
me disent que trump a des chances qui
bon mais mais individuellement ne cette
responsabilité-là essayer de s'exposer
un plus grand nombre de sources
possibles écoutes et des balados du new
york times mais écoutez aussi de
ballades aux banshee pire haut à droite
pour juste voir ils sont dans quelle
dose tu sais l'a écoutée par maxime et
moi si je disais le sens l'armée mais
j'en reviens toujours sur ce parce qu' à
chaque fois je me dis acquis mais j
aimerais ça je veux m'exposer de soins
mais 75% des sources d'information
qu'elle je m'expose critique la
présidence de nos 30 et puis je dirais
j'essaie il de chercher ailleurs que
juste le délit l'été sauf que les lits
25% qui sont pros tron qu'on dirait que
tu écoutes se pisse au cul n'y a pas de
rigueur si c'est n'importe quoi puis-je
me dit est ce que c'est juste parce que
c'est matt selon ma perception que c'est
n'importe quoi
ouais tu aimais tant 4 quand t'écoutes
un reportage à fox news fixé c'est des
attaques personnelles envers
kamala harris tchèque est en train
d'écouter ses tubes vraiment c'est us à
s'exposer à l'autre côté ouais fox news
monstre c'est un cas c'est un cas
évidemment classique là d'un réseau qui
est très très orienté c'est pas faire
une balade à ce que leur slogan disait
mais je dirais que cnn est presque aussi
pire maintenant mais c'est classe je les
regardais encore hier puis monsieur les
mènent bon c est intéressant à regarder
tous hommes y sont de plus en plus dans
l'opinion je trouvais ses tresses et 24
heures sur 24 à casser du sucre sur le
dos de monsieur thuram qui a fox news
bas c'est le contraire nbc ci-dessus
quelque chose de correct ou est
peut-être oui mais je dirais il ya le
bal à dos de belle-mère que j'aime
écouter vous le connaissez sans doute le
numéro est ce lui la ses opinions c'est
clair mais je trouve qu'il reçoit quand
même à son bal à doha son émission des
démocrates des républicains et à s'être
trouvé un équilibre là dedans sinon ben
donc je trouve que c'est de plus en plus
difficile honnêtement j'écoute des
balados comme de beaux work
il ya quelques ballades aux où on essaie
de trouver un équilibre on est un peu
plus au centre
mais aimer ce qui est plate aussi avec
les baladeurs un peu plus au centre
c'est qu'ils ont tendance à écarter les
gens très très à gauche où les gens très
très adroite de la discussion si c'est
pas de l'extrême sens mais ça devient un
peu on est au centre
donc non c'est de plus en plus difficile
donc je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix
d'aller butiner et de lire un livre
aussi lire une coupe de livres quand je
trouve qu'on et puis moi aussi le tanto
avant le bal ado je disais à la blague
que je dors très segmenté comme un aveu
je dors avec mon téléphone on est on lit
li on est beaucoup sur les médias
sociaux ah et on finit par se rabattre
sur trois quatre sources qui nous
enferme dans une bulle idéologique je
trouve cette plus en plus difficile de
se détacher de ça il faut faire les
formes qui malheureusement on a moins de
temps qu'avant aussi je trouve même le
concept d'impartialité il tellement flou
l'impression parce que tu mets ton fils
présidente quelque chose dit quelque
chose qui est factuellement faux après
ce sujet actif il est faible mais non
c'est pas vrai la vérité c'est ce le
fait c'est ce mélange me positionne
contre le président armand réalité
j'essaie juste de rétablir les faits tu
sais pas ça mon sens pas partisan de
rechercher la vérité de juste dire la
vraie affaire soit que lui tourne ce de
manière bab sebaa new york times
on sait bien vous vous êtes vous êtes
content - dan à la fac c'est
l'impression quelqu'un qui était un
président qui est tellement je te mords
subjectif et points et pas impartial ou
vraiment et qui veut dire vous dire
justement des choses qui fait
actuellement font qu'un sens après seul
il y medio au dollar tenté de le ramener
à l'ordre quand que j essaie juste de
trouver une objectivité là dedans dit
ouais et ça va même plus loin nous on
trouve pas mal la politique américaine
on commente pas mal la politique
américaine dans les médias justement on
est souvent invité à commenter ce qui se
passe puisque sauf qu'au cours des
quatre dernières années on nous a
appelés à commenter des choses comme
celles là un bain puis un moment donné
tu dis baisse ce que le président entre
hommes dit ne résiste pas à l'épreuve
des faits c'est ça je le dis c'est tout
et on reçoit quand même régulièrement
des courriels de de gens au québec qui
nous disent vous êtes biaisé vous êtes
vous jouez le jeu des médias tout ça
alors que quand obama était au pouvoir
faisait même choisir en fait il ça
arrivait qu'on disait dans ce cas ci on
pense que le président fait erreur on
pense que bon sa décision n'a pas
produit les effets escomptés c'est sûr
que les déclarations d'obama résiste un
peu plus souvent l'épreuve des faits
selon des sites comme politifact et
d'autres sites comme ça mais on sait on
s'est pas empêché de critiquer des
présidents démocrates également à la
chaire raoul dandurand je vous dirais qu
une belle diversité de points de vue
aussi on est des on a des gens à droite
on est des gens très très à gauche et on
arrive à avoir un dialogue intéressant
et je pense que c'est le rôle de
l'université aussi mais il ya quand même
trempe aurait des appuis au québec dans
certains milieux on le voit on reçoit
souvent des courriels de gens qui nous
disent vous êtes vendu vous êtes ceci
cela alors que le travail c'est l'effet
way aussi de c2c de le dire quand le
président s'est contredit a dit une
chose qui ne résistent pas à l'épreuve
des faits oui on dit surtout quand on
nous pose la question je pense qu'il
faut juste rectangle ce qui est ce que
dans votre position peu dans les médias
qui a la charge est tenu de rester le
plus impartiale possible qu'il y ait
plus justement d'observer de manière
plus objective ce qui se passe ou bien
c'est toujours teinté par vous cette
opinion personnelle je dirais que en
recherche les ja il ya deux types de
chercheurs il ya des chercheurs qui
croient que c'est possible d'être
objectif quand on analyse tout ça il ya
des chercheurs qui ont qui conçoit alors
leurs rots qui conçoivent leur rôle
d'intellectuel de façon un petit peu
plus engagé c'est à dire le rôle des
chercheurs devraient de déconstruire les
discours dominants qui crée des
injustices au sein de nos sociétés tout
ça donc à la charia des chercheurs qui
sont plus normatif dans leur approche
c'est à dire qu'ils vont critiquer le
président puis ils voient leur rôle
comme ça il y en a d'autres qui vont
essayer de prendre un petit peu de recul
en 10 ans ben ça c'est pas mon rôle moi
j'observe ce qui se pense que je vous
décris ce qui se passe voici ce que les
sondages disent voici quelles sont les
chances de troc de gagner tout ça tue
moi comme directeur de la chaire ce que
j'aime c'est de laisser à chacun chacune
la liberté de faire les choses un peu
comme il le souhaite et si ça qui donne
les meilleures discussions parce
qu'honnêtement on en revient ce qu'on
disait tantôt là quand tu te disais j'ai
de la misère à trouver haché pas
média où j'ai de la diversité oui c'est
vrai puis je sais moi d'éviter ça dans
notre gang
sinon bah je trouve pas ce stimulant je
me remets pas en question ses sages et
mettre des filles et moi aussi dans mes
certitudes des fois là tout meilleurs le
terme et ont personnellement tu voyais
pas tant que ce sens que tu mets ton
tantôt je disais depuis deux cent mille
morts aux etats unis tout sens qu'il ya
deux cent quinze mille morts petite
femme aux street
c'est ce que les critiques qui lui
reprochent sa voix de barzun ouais mais
j'imagine que c'est une déformation le
professionnel d'essayer de rester mais
j'imagine que si tous regardé ce dès
fois piètre complètement subjuguée
ouais ben les 215 milles morts si tu
veux que je te parle un peu plus
personnellement je sais qu'à un moment
donné on connaît des gens aux états unis
qui ont qui ont qui ont des membres de
leur famille sont décédés qui ont été
malades qui ont des séquelles de son
encore aujourd'hui qui sont encore
confiné parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
décision qui ont permis de régler ça
rapidement c'est sûr que ça c'est le
genre d'affaires qui me forge le jeu je
pense pas que ça a été géré tout à fait
correctement le problème dans ce pays là
c'est que le pouvoir est quand même très
décentralisé aussi et je vais pas excusé
30 mais il ya quand même une limite
parce que le président peut faire ce
nouveau pays plus de 3,5 millions
d'habitants
il ya un gouvernement beaucoup de
pouvoir et c'est pour ça que je dis mais
en fait je lis pas dit encore mais ce
que je dirais sexy byden est élu oui va
il va écouter un petit peu plus les
scientifiques oui pour être tentés de
dire il faut une directive nationale
pour le port du masque et tout ça mais
il va y avoir beaucoup de résistance
dans ce pays là de la part de
gouvernants républicains notamment qui
vont continuer à dire ce que trame dit
en ce moment donc c'est loin d'être
réglé et je sais pas je dis n'importe
quoi mais si obama avait été au pouvoir
pendant cette pandémie la la même
pandémie mais avec un président très
différent barack obama
aussi byden avait été au pouvoir je sais
pas ignorer combien de mort aux états
unis en aurait pas eu ce 0 non plus
n'ont donc oui je trouve ça grave ce qui
se passe c'est clair puis je trouve ça
d'autant plus grave que c'est un pays
que j'aime beaucoup personnellement les
choses que j'aime moins dans ce pays
l'homme et des choses que j'aime
beaucoup et le fait que la frontière
canado américaine soit fermée aux
voyages non essentiels le fait qu'on
puisse pas aller sur le terrain pour
étudier ces élections là cet automne moi
je trouve ça je trouve ça plate
personnellement qu'il me demande quand
est ce qu'on va être capable de gérer
cette affaire là et j'ai pas
l'impression qu'avec ça va être très
rapide avec ce président là pour le
moment quand je vois l'attitude qu'il à
l'espèce de nonchalance on n'écoute pas
trop les scientifiques
donc là je suis un peu plus dans le
personnel je dirais même un autre un
autre enjeu qui qu'imagine voir et où le
très important aux élections dans deux
semaines c'est là les enjeux de justice
sociale et un énorme mais leur mouvement
puis une des raisons pourquoi joe biden
etc explique vous avoir voulu rentrer
dans la course présidentielle c'était
surtout aux manifestations à
charlottesville ou est ce que le
président avait dire qu'il y avait des
bons d'un deux côtés il était alors que
c'était des jeunes qui manifestaient
contre le racisme bicoque mde soit super
merci du kkk de l'autre côté l'éthique
ce climat l'attention aux états unis et
probablement en occident le pays en ce
moment où est-ce qu'on est ce que ça
situe dans les enjeux puis dans
l'importance à ces élections là qui
quels vont être les répercussions du
vote de deux paires de différentes
ethnies en fait dans le vent ce vote le
combat team en autant d'années pour ce
qui est de l'importance de l'enjeu la cc
le troisième enjeu le plus important est
que le canot virus ouais parce que le
corps un navire russe la cave et 19 tu
as
l'enjeu du leadership gouvernemental qui
est liée à toutes sortes de questions
dont celle là mais il est il est défini
comme ça dans les sondages de l'iss
tu gardes pour leadership les gens sont
vos références notamment la mauvaise
gestion des affaires de la nation par le
président entre rome et les tensions
raciales arrivant troisième luc
l'économie en quatrième donc c'est un
enjeu super important ah et oui ça
brasse dans ce pays là il ya eu des
manifestations dans les 50 états unis
qui depuis l'assassinât de john floyd
aumône mais quel effet ça peut avoir sur
le vote
ce qui est curieux vous allez trouver ça
curieux je pense c'est que trump
pourrait mieux faire auprès des
électeurs afro-américains qu'en 2005
ce sont les données ce sont les données
que j'ai vu en carrière il est 1 11 %
d'appuis au prg environ auprès des
électeurs afro américains en ce moment
byden et à 84 pour cent d'appuis on
pourrait penser habituellement que le
candidat démocrate à 90 pour cent
d'appuis 91 peut-être un peu plus
et pour ce qui est des électeurs latino
américains je pourrais revenir aux
afro-américains par la suite mais pour
ce qui est des électeurs latino
américaine trempé a à peu près 30 %
d'appui auprès de cet électorat là on
pourrait revenir tantôt mais ouais ça
vous étonne un oui oui tout à fait
qu'est ce qui explique ce mais pour ce
qui est des des électeurs
afro-américains ce que je dirais c'est
que le discours de trump qui consiste à
dire qu'en réduisant les impôts tout le
monde quand qu'en misant sur l'économie
on peut permettre à tous les américains
d' améliorer leur existence ça trouve un
certain écho auprès d'une petite partie
des électeurs afro américaine mais quand
même il énonce %
mais c'est sûr qu'après ça tout son
discours sur la loi et l'ordre
toutes les vies comptes au lieu de black
cats marais et tout ça c'est sûr que
c'est pas très payant il leur fut aussi
de
condamner les ouates supprimer six noms
cités bol de tiers répétition il se fait
poser la question puis jamais capable de
formuler la phrase qu'elle veut
l'entendre exact donc il entretient
cette espèce d'ambiguïté la sur le
mouvement qu on a nos systèmes back
stand by c10 il dit ça puis adressé le
lendemain il se fait discret pour des
questions qui se passe dans nos mc ça
c'est clair
le président a cité connaît pas t'es pas
qualifiés pour un peu triste mais il
joue souvent sur ce tableau leur espèce
d'ambiguïté puis sur les mouvements
nationalistes blancs il joue sur cette
ambiguïté parce qu'il sait qu'il a des
appuis récemment d'exil appui en vue de
l'élection du 3 novembre puis la
campagne électorale de preuves on dit
est une sélection c'est une élection où
il est convaincu qu'il peut gagner comme
en 2016 grâce à sa base avec sa base qui
va il va tout faire pour maintenir ces
gens-là unis en vue du 3 novembre mais
pour s'assurer qu'ils vont aller voter
donc ici je pense qu'il sait très bien
qui sont les pros boys leurs
institutions mais mes os des bords il se
pose la question puis décide de jouer la
carte de l'ambiguïté en disant si je les
dénonce
je nuis à mon électeurs en jeu nuit en
fait à mes appuis auprès de ma base
électorale et lendemain il doit
finalement je les connaissais pas je
sais pas trop ce que j'ai dit puis mais
on s'en fout parce que le débat ait fini
puis les gens écoutent - ce qui dit le
lendemain que qui regardent le débat le
soir du débat
et pour ce qui est des électeurs latino
américains ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que c'est pas ce pas un bloc homogène
bon mais je pense que vous le savez mais
a parmi les électeurs latino américains
on ad on a dit on a des des
ressortissants qubec habite miami qui
déteste le régime leur
castriste skis à ce qui reste de ce
régime là à cuba et qui appuie le parti
républicain parce que le parti
républicain est plus tough à l'égard de
ce régime là que les démocrates
puis plus loin d'un communisme en guinée
ou six mois exactement
et aussi ce qu'il faut retenir des
électeurs latino américains c'est qu'on
en a beaucoup qui sont très très
pratique qui sont très pratiquants qui
vont à l'église toutes les semaines et
qui préfèrent les positions des
républicains sur des enjeux comme
l'avortement le mariage gai tout ça et
pour ce qui est des électeurs
afro-américains latino américaine ce qui
va compter aussi c'est leur
participation électorale
ce sont des électeurs qui ont plus de
difficultés à s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales pour toutes sortes de
raisons de poing internet
c'est difficile de t'inscrire sur
internet tu es moins fortunés tu n'as
pas de voiture c'est plus difficile de
te rendre là où tu dois te rendre pour
récupérer la documentation nécessaire
pour s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales
donc il ya tout ce qui fait que ça ce
sont des électeurs très très important
chaque élection mais la participation
électorale est moins forte
et ça ça peut jouer aussi en contexte de
pandémie là où il ya beaucoup de vote
par la poste où il ya beaucoup de mai
mais c'est sa trompe pas encore quand
même certains appuis auprès des latino
américains c'est clair auprès des
afro-américains aux six nouvelles
lettres même fermé auprès de ses
électeurs le camp 2016
enfin on en parlera justement de tout ce
que ça implique l'espèce de vote à
distance votre anticipation puis se met
avant justement de ce qu'on vient sur la
crise et les tensions raciales aux
tats-unis pas de calais encore
l'impression que comme tout c'est mon
opinion personnelle mais comme pour le
chrono virus une très mauvaise gestion
de cette crise le où justement il quitte
presque non gestion dans le sens qu'il
ya un problème puis au lieu de tenter de
le régler
on fait un peu prier ou même des fois on
met de l'huile sur le feu pour faire
plaisir à une base puis encore une fois
je trouve ça vraiment je trouve ça
vraiment laid cette manière de procéder
là où est ce que une grise tes pieds des
gens qui sautent de crise le ya des
conséquences à cette crise le mai haut
lieu
mais comme l allemand bonne pour lui le
fait d'avoir une crise le fait de
pouvoir consolider sa base à martelant
la loi et leur depuis ce bain il la
laisse dégénéré était plutôt que de la
règle et source vraiment je trouve que
c'est comme la politique passe avant
l'intérêt public le tout je pense que ta
dernière phrase est la plus importante
pour comprendre ce qui se passe qui
malheureusement se soit on regarde pas
ça pas de sens la sphère george clooney
visage comme moi qui peux accepter une
affaire comme ça il peut accepter une
affaire comme ça personne c'est inhumain
et c'était terrible et d'histoire comme
ça il y en a des tonnes et des tonnes et
des tonnes depuis que ce pays là
existent et les choses ne changent pas
quand quand je donne ma séance sur sur
les dix ont sur les relations raciales
dans mon cours à l'uqam magny cours à
l'uqam
souvent ce que je dis c'est que c'est
une séance qui que je n'ai presque pas
un jour malheureusement les statistiques
sur les inégalités entre les blancs et
les noirs les difficultés d'accès aux
meilleures universités les difficultés
d'accès au vote et tout ça ce sont des
choses qui évoluent qui n'évolue presque
pour trop lendemain mais est ce que tu
disais très important tron veut gagner
il veut juste gagner l'élection il est
là c'est pas juste moi qui le dit les
lobes pour lui avant tout - hockey et
son pari c'était de dire qu'il pouvait
grâce à son thème sur la loi et l'ordre
fait ressortir sa base électorale et
peut-être y peut-être gagner des votes
dans les banlieues aux états unis parce
que y'a une partie de cette élection là
qui joue dans les banlieues et surtout
les électrices blanche des banlieues qui
en ce moment il dit beaucoup
dernièrement les ans waris demi
il ya des gens qui la regarde et qui
disent bon il est un peu désespéré parce
qu'ils réalisent bien qui a perdu des
appuis auprès des électrices blanche des
banlieues sont pas risquer quoi c'est à
dire qu'il ya une élection je veux la
gagner cette élection là je vais jouer
sur la peur ok et enjoint sur la part je
vais essayer de convaincre des
électrices blanche des banlieues de
voter un petit peu plus pour moi et son
idée c'est quoi c'est dire ça c'est ce
que vous voyez dans les villes
américaines en ce moment comme kenosha
os quand scène minneapolis au minnesota
et tout ça si on n'arrête pas ça avec
les forces policières la loi et l'homme
ça va s'étendre jusque dans les
banlieues américaines unsa vont menacer
vos familles ça va menacer vos enfants
et tout ça il ya l'image les deux
couples qui sont sortis sur la sur leur
terrain et arval qu'il y avait une
manifestation la russe avait aucun sens
exact mais une image forte qu'on a
montrée sur le réseau fox news notamment
pour pour dire quoi à pour dire ben
c'est ça qui nous attend si on va pas de
l'avant avec 30 parce que ben laden est
plus faible sur ces questions là il veut
écouter tout ça il est même proche des
mouvements
merci même proche des mouvements la
gauche de la classe matelas anti feu et
tout ça c'est pas l'aimer c'est ça c est
pendant ce temps là on ne règle pas
vraiment le problème hein on le voit ça
continue il ya beaucoup de
mécontentement moi j'étais j'étais prof
invités à berkeley en californie en 2015
ni le mouvement black l'admr de l'été
actif dans le quartier chez nous où
j'habitais donc ça fait déjà un bon
moment se fait déjà cinq ans que ces
mouvements là tentent de se faire
entendre on a l'impression ils ont
l'impression que personne ne les échos
depuis les images de georgetown moi j'en
reviens à soc on est en 2020 leur comme
un week end ou bâle
mais ce président allende n'a pas on a
l'impression que trump ne voit pas la
société américaine selon ces lignes de
fracture le parce que j'en reviens ce
que je disais tantôt dit les afro
américaine m'adore les latino
américaines à dar parce que
rassam et à mars est à mes recettes sur
le plan économique
j'améliore l'avis de tout le monde
j'améliore levitte tout le monde mais en
fait c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça parce que et ça c'est lyndon johnson
qu'il l'avait dit quand il a essayé de
mettre un terme au système de
ségrégation raciale dans le sud des
états unis dans les années soixante dix
on améliore les choses mais c'est pas
vrai que tout le monde doit partir c'est
la même ligne de départ dès demain matin
et en 2020 on en est encore leur nom
donc quand rome du tout le monde
s'améliore pas à la même vitesse
c'est juste que si ce conflit-là
dégénère mais ton petit dans un monde où
ça dégénère vraiment qui c'est ça vire à
la guerre civile par exemple le tien
c'est totalement irresponsable
mais tu sais j'ai l'impression que c'est
rendu comme seul sait se faire élire
avant tout mais pour moi chaud ce jour
je trouve ça dégueulasse était de de
laisser pourrir d'aider les enjeux comme
ceux pour ton propre game mais certains
disent que ce sont 30 et les membres de
son entourage sont très très cynique
dans leur vision de la politique vous
avez peut-être vu le documentaire game
you were just ton nom sur netflix
waterstone c'est l'ancien conseiller de
tremplin durant la campagne électorale
de 2005 sion de ses anciens conseillers
d'ailleurs il ya été a été pris dans
toute cette histoire
quand l'abonnement leur a fait son
enquête sur la
l'implication de la russie dans
l'élection 2016 mme on a réalisé que
rodgers tourne finalement vers avait mal
agi dans ce dossier là en tentant
d'avoir des contacts avec wikileaks et
essayer d'en informer le président
tromper tout ça et voir justin a été
visé par cette affaire là mais dans le
documentaire on le voit dans l'entourage
de tram qui dit une phrase très très
importante on veut gagner à tout prix
on va tout faire pour gagner sauf violé
les lois
ok mais en 2016 il dit c'est ça qu'il
faut il faut il faut vraiment et c'est
cynique dans une certaine mesure parce
qu'il n'ya plus rien qui compte souffre
le gain sauf la victoire électorale
et c'est notamment lui qui est à la base
de cette idée de dire en 2016 alors
qu'europe en parlant d'hillary clinton
et je dirais que cet état d'esprit-là
caractérise encore la vision de 30 en
2010 à dire on va tout faire pour gagner
vous déstabiliser et on est un peu dans
cet état d'esprit lanka donc c'est
difficile pour nous deux qui moi je dis
souvent aux gens de mon entourage d'un
j'essaie d'être une bonne personne si je
j'essaie de m'en tire le moins possible
j'essaie de jeu n'est pas capable dormir
le soir à mais on n'est pas fait de
l'art tout cas moi je suis pas fait de
la même façon je pense non et cette
espèce de cynisme en politique la de
dire on va tout faire pour gagner puis
ça nous empêche pas de dormir le soir ça
peut être ça peut paraître un peu
étrange me ad il ya des gens qui sont
quand même dans cet été dans cet état
d'esprit là je trouve ça surprenant que
en fait il fait son quatre ans au
complet non-sens quelqu'un qui avait été
élu prend la personne incroyable 12ème
allemands disaient si tu es lui il va
avoir une controverse
on va boire une enquête qui vote qu'il
faut trouver quelque chose va faire
qu'il va être destitué ou quoi que ce
soit puis j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu
tellement beaucoup de d'épée de damoclès
en haut de sa tête durant sa présidence
il n'y a pas une qui est tombé le ti
avait dit il y avait des des accusations
d'agression sexuelle
et justement l'ingérence russe
d'ailleurs dans l'île de bowers
quand il apprend qui va avoir cette
enquête le il dit à mme fu ça veut dire
que si quelqu'un qui arrive à
s'approcher est pas sans l'autre et puis
j'ai l'impression que je te marty plus y
avait les pitchouns des tentatives
d'empêchement ce fut finalement ce
goller ricochet toute son évasion
fiscale
il y avoue ça vient pas de moi f london
avoué mais ici dit comme on sait si
c'est pas qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
évitent les andré qui cammas et de la
cave est d'éviter toutes les
controverses là encore les récemment si
avoué qui doit 400 millions c'est pas
qu'ils pillent il ya tellement
d'affaires finalement mais en fait ce
qui aurait pas fallu être surpris mais
ton qui façon 4 en considérant qui a été
élu après qui a été pris en tripartite
graber de possibles capable d'éviter ce
qui t'attend il est c'est vrai car 2016
quand on a vu ça là moi je pense l'avoir
dit aussi on se dit c'est fini c'est
fini la campagne est finie les
finalement un look le groupe d'orques le
dacquois qui se voit j'en reviens à ce
que je disais tantôt ses partisans elle
adore 1 là bas si viceira way le culte
de la personnalité presque puis si ça
qui fait qu'il est encore là parce que
si on regarde je veux pas trop parler de
son d'argent encore parce que bon mais
si on regarde les données de sondage
une 90% des électeurs républicains
l'appui encore mais quatre ans non un
peu importe ce qui a fait près portique
c'est parce et puis c'est ça le socle de
sa présidence est ce qui fait qu est
encore là et c'est ça qui fait que c'est
difficile pour les autres républicains
dans la machine à washington de le
critiquer parce que sur le pitch bend ce
qui l'a sauvé c'est le sénat qui était
républicain et
le fait que les républicains ont tous
fermer leur gueule entre guillemets ion
incident et de le garder au pouvoir
récemment ils ont le républicain qui est
sorti en disant que dans le privé il se
posait à tremblay gardait toutes ces
oppositions privé ben ça pique nique et
finalement c'était je pense tous les
shows de stephen colbert qui disait que
dans toutes lés toutes les occasions où
est ce qu'il ya eu à voter pour ou
contre des lois trump est à 98 9% avec
trois valeurs qui faisaient dans le
privé il était vraiment compte beaucoup
de ses idées oui ils ont tous et autres
meurent de faim ils ont par de 30 pour
la raison que j'ai évoqué les 90 pour
cent d'appuis dans le parti républicain
a et trump est quelqu'un qui va vous
intimider lorsqu'il aura la chance de le
faire si vous l'avez critiquer ni je me
rappelle du lendemain des élections de
mi-mandat de 2018
il ya eu des élections en 2018 deux ans
après l'élection présidentielle les
républicains ont perdu des plumes
ils ont perdu la chambre des
représentants et le lendemain de
l'élection
je me rappellerai toujours de sa trempe
prend la parole en conférence de presse
puis un homme les républicains qui ont
perdu et qu'il l'avait critiqué jusque
là est un homme d les chaînes cernay
espace énorme en public je vous l'avais
dit continue à m'appuyer parce que c'est
ce qui vous attend est un bout il
aux états unis il ya les élections
générales mais avant les élections
générales il ya des élections primaires
on est sur du côté des élections
présidentielles mais il y en a aussi
pour pour les autres postes leurs
représentants sénateurs et tout ça et
quand on critique trop ce qu'il fait
c'est qu'ils appuient mettons tue un
républicain tulle critique il va appuyer
un autre républicain ou une autre
républicaine pour te battre à la
primaire républicaine avant même
l'élection générale aux etats-unis ont
dit yu dans mon toubib prime reid tu
veux pas te faire planter à la primaire
dans ton parti avant l'élection générale
et c'est comme ça qu'il garde y réussir
à forcer les républicains en silence
parce que il est très populaire auprès
des électeurs
puis il dit au fond c'est une critique
soit mangé une volée je vais je vais
tweeté à ton propos je vais bien toute
sorte d'exemple de deux républicains qui
ont complètement changé de discours à
l'égard de tremplin entre 2016 et 2020
bien de cela c'est antirépublicain la
céline et g
le sénateur de la caroline du sud qui en
2016 durant les primaires républicaines
en vue de la présidentielle de 2016 dit
si dans notre shop est élu on s'envoie
direct dans mad à l'eau je me souviens
pas des mots qu'ils emploient ni très
critique il dit presque c'est un foule
regardez l'insee g aujourd'hui c'est le
poisson pilote de trompe il dit il dit
exactement ce que trame dit l'appui
trempe à fond le train mais c'est que
lindsey graham a eu peur de se faire
pointer du doigt par train mais là les
agoras mais quand même en difficulté en
vue de son élection le 3 novembre j'ai
hâte de voir ce que ça va même de son
équipe le thé et mettons les personnes
qui est nommé secrétaire d'état à la
défense il y avait un tu voté pour moi
puis mode su appuyer pitié s'il se
rendait compte que y'avait pas toujours
eu la halle un appui à 100% cette
personne aurait été 10 cartes et une la
loyauté est très très importante pour
lui très important de produits encore
une fois je pense que c'est lié à son à
son background têtu est à la tête d'un
empire lempire trom tu t'entoures de
membres de ta famille et qui ont une
loyauté indéfectible à ton égard ses
enfants bon l'air de l'aimer je pense
qu'il aime ses enfants sincèrement aussi
il dit toujours que ses filles sont sont
géniaux ivanka trump et quand tu es dans
un environnement comme ça ou où on dit
que tu est excellent on dit que tu es et
il a besoin de ça il n'a besoin que les
médias parlent en bien de lui je pense
est important la loyauté très importante
pour lui
ils exigent ça de la part des
républicains sauf que c'est pas un
système qui est fait pour fonctionner
comme ça il n'ya pas habituellement n'ya
pas de discipline de parti automatique
dans ce système là elle est plus forte
moins forte selon les périodes
mais on a vu dans le passé des
démocrates et des républicains faire
front commun congrès pour voter contre
le président démocrate ou un président
républicain mais 30 n'accepte personnes
ok ai dit si vous êtes républicain vous
êtes de mon côté ou sinon je vous pointe
du doigt je twitte à votre propos vous
allez manger une volée au prochain la
paix le pires châtiments un tout y est
même même son vice-président le mike
pence
je peux pas croire quelqu'un qui est ta
maison avec sa femme dans le privé il ya
personne qui écoute le qui est
approaches and castle moi je pense est
peut-être celui qui est le plus loyal
envers ce président là s'est il est
d'une discipline à yaya jammeh c'est un
de ceux parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont capable de bouger qu'une mouche
sa tête pas marre de ces suppliques
qu'il est là tu veux montrer aucun signe
de faiblesse mais c'est lui qui te
croyais fervent croyant et edward jamais
tellement une personne immoral temps et
surtout plein plein que je peux pas
croire qu'ils endossent mais lorsque je
dirais c'est que moi je suis d'accord je
pense je suis d'accord avec toi je pense
que mike pence et bon c'est justement
ces croyances religieuses font sans
sortie est difficile pour lui de dire
que trempé et purée il s'était fait
parfait ici mais comme ta gueule grèce
le sourire fait quand on demande à celle
du leader est un crime barbare bible
c'est ça quand même table pour ces
républicains conservateurs moraux
religieux la sq il plus important c'est
ce que je disais un peu plus tôt la
nomination des juges conservateurs dans
l'ue notamment la cour suprême surtout
pour l'avortement ses instincts dossier
tellement super important l'important
est au fond c'est ces républicains
conservateurs moraux en viennent à dire
que trump est pas parfait mais c'est
encore mieux que n'importe quel
démocrate à maison blanche et
il ya des gens aussi qui établit sur le
parallèle entre ce que trump et c'est
d'incarner et un discours biblique qui
met l'accent sur l'idée qu'il ya des
sauveurs parfois dans nos sociétés des
gens qui voient carrément et mais sinon
exactement et regarde les messi qui joue
dans maman j'ai raté l'avion de messi le
visuel est l'idée c'est de dire que la
société américaine est mal en point
elle est sur le déclin elle est
contrôlée
si on fait lien avec les théories qdn
par des élites politiques et économiques
du dip state un dip state qui a qui
profitent des gens depuis trop longtemps
il faut changer ça et rome peut être vu
comme cette espèce de darksiders où est
le messie qui va changer les choses une
bonne fois pour toute et qui sur les
questions morales et peut-être pas
parfait mais il va il va défendre nos
intérêts pour vrai d'importance que pour
vrai parce qu'il devrait en fait ce qui
est vrai thomas puis les conservateurs
moraux se sont déjà ont déjà été très
très déçu de présidents républicains qui
avaient entre hommes disaient qu'ils
allaient défendre leurs intérêts pour
vrai et ronald reagan mais george w.bush
aussi qui avait dit en 2004 avant sa
réélection
je souhaiterais qu'un amendement la
constitution des états unis pour
interdire le mariage gay partout au pays
mais ce que les conservateurs moraux
réaliser c'est que il ya beaucoup de
républicains qui disait ce genre de
chose en campagne électorale pour gagner
l'élection mais après ça c'était fini je
pensais rien avec tron il le dit en
campagne électorale pile il le fait
notamment les trois juges à la cour
suprême qui sont très très très
conservateur sur ces questions là et si
vous regardez le vote évangélique qui a
un des votes importants parmi les votes
des électeurs de la droite chrétienne si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi c'est ce qu'on
constate c'est que le vote le vote
évangélique est encore au rendez-vous
les protestants évangéliques vont voter
massivement pour tromper encore même si
stormy daniels même si
parce que même si la liste est longue
mais oui parce qu'on est prêt à faire
ses compromis l'a momentanément en ainsi
un petit moment peut-être parce qu'on
sait que les les changements avoir
déclenché de longue haleine exactement
pour les même faits réels de penser puis
ben shapiro dont on parle est un taudis
sens propre du mot trompe je trouve
complètement il le dit encore dans son
baladeur récemment et je comprends pas
sa stratégie électorale complètement
ridicule mais dit souvent j'ai voté pour
lui je vais probablement voter pour lui
encore à cause de ça parce que ça c'est
le plus intimement sont les enjeux les
plus importants pour moi c'est
certainement pas elizabeth warren bernis
en deux jours byden qui avait fait mieux
que tremplin à mes yeux que je traîne
chez toi
après c'est sa ses protégés à toi mais
je suis conscient là dessus c'est quand
même c'est quand même fou d'elle l'idée
qui était de dire le mettre des bâtons
dans les roues mariages gris ou
l'avortement dans son argument pour
gagner une élection c'est là qu'on se
rend compte qu'on ne vit pas dans le
même pays et aux états unis les faits
ouaip mais il ya une dynamique
électorale puis à des il ya des
électeurs à qui votent plus que d'autres
ouais parce que on parlait bernie
sanders tantôt on est allé sur le
terrain avec l'équipe l'an en 2018 puis
en 2020 au début des primaires juste
avant la pandémie si on interagit avec
toutes les équipes de campagne démocrate
tous les partisans de bernie sanders amy
klobuchar pitbull de jeju byden j'ai
parlé à joe biden au new hampshire en
février dernier dans un petit peu avec
lui on a parlé avec leur équipe est si
vrai que bernie sanders suscite
l'enthousiasmé beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes électeurs qui sont
complètement écoeuré de ce système qui
ont vécu avec la crise économique qu'on
vient en ce moment deux crises
économiques situés incluent celles de
deux mille 2000 2007 2008 2009 et ça
commence mal en outre ils vendent et
étudiants de 150 mille pièces qui le
tuteur choix de joe biden puis dans
l'autre choc donc c'est vrai que bernie
à suscite beaucoup beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé auprès des jeunes
électeurs
malheureusement ce qui est plate c'est
que les jeunes électeurs sont
les électeurs qui votent pas toujours
beaucoup aux élections
c'est un électorat qui est peut-être un
peu moins fiables je sais pas si c'est
le bon mot mais que l'électorat
évangélique dont je parlais tantôt donc
pourquoi ils gagnent trump sait qu'il
est capable de mobiliser entre autres
des électorats sont peu représentative
nécessairement des valeurs de l'ensemble
la société mais qui sont très très
motivés à aller voter qui vote le jour
de l'élection pour ce jeu te poser la
question tantôt c'est l'impression que
malgré le comportement qui semble
complètement désorganisée pratique de
notre homme
les gens qui votent pour lui finalement
il livre quand même marchandise était si
toi tu veux tu es des positions plus
conservatrices sur des questions comme
ceux comme le mariage quelques comme
l'avortement
tu dis que des jeux et cour suprême
contre torch veulent moins d'impôts tu
veux moins de traiter tu veux
l'environnement l'accord de paris de
trader
ils livrent la marchandise paraît
ettifaq et j'ai besoin de beaucoup de
gens je t'aime comme tu dis à dos paul à
personne mais en dos
ces politiques puis finalement c'est
politique nous sommes aux célébrités
avec des guirlandes et encore higdon
pareil là dessus et puis quand on était
dans il ya tout ce que tu viens de dire
qu'il ya un autre élément qui est très
important aussi car quand on est allé
dans le midwest des états-unis en 2018
on le fait on a visité les trois 3 ans
fait deux des trois états très très
important aux élections présidentielles
on ne visite est en fait le le mini
sauta on est à l'e3 et en talons
ministre autant os cantine puis excuse
moi au michigan
et quand on regarde la carte électorale
de 2016
trump a surpris tout le monde en gagnant
au risque antinomie chic en paix en
pennsylvanie unique on était là-bas je
sais pas si vous êtes allez mr
c'est une région américaine très très
intéressante super le fun mais sur le
déclin sur le déclin parce que les
emplois manufacturiers l'industrie de
l'automobile dans le coin détroit et
tout ça c'est très difficile depuis
depuis un certain nombre d'années depuis
quelques décennies et ce sont des gens
qui attendent quelque chose depuis
longtemps un candidat présidente
présidentielle qui va dire je suis là
pour vous
on va essayer de changer les choses pour
vous
pour vrai cette fois ci j'en reviens à
ça pour vrai et trump en 2016 à 10 a dit
là c'en est assez
on va essayer de relancer ces villes
essayer de relancer ces états là sur le
plan économique mais c'est peut-être la
première ce qui est moins le tout moins
tenu en fuite ben que moins fonctionné
il a essayé avec les nouveaux accords de
commerce là ces hommes pour les fermiers
du s cantine les tarifs sur l'acier
l'aluminium à l'égard de la chaîne et du
canada en disant on va essayer de
relancer l'industrie de l'acier c'est
important au mini sauteur limin l'abord
c'est important kent ok et les gens
aujourd'hui si vous parlez à ses
personnages à beaucoup de gens qui vous
disent effectivement ma vie a pas changé
du tout au tout en quatre ans glisse et
ça c'est important si ça peut tout
changer mais j'ai encore l'impression
qu'ils croient à ce qui veut tout faire
pour nous redonner de bons emplois dans
les régions qui sont sur le déclin
j'ai bon je sais pas d'où vous venez au
québec moi je suis né à alma au
lac-saint-jean clip tout neuf coupes des
neiges coûte 6000 forme c'est que
l'industrie de l'aluminium est très
important dans la région puis il ya
beaucoup de villes dont al mc sont dix
villes qui dépendent beaucoup de
l'industrie ou deux industries si ça ça
tombe à prêcher pour ce qui reste dans
le midwest beaucoup de villes et de coin
comme ceux où les politiciens se
succèdent et ils ne font rien pour
essayer de sauver la vie de ces gens là
soit un économie et trompe a été le
premier je dirais depuis quelques
décennies à à les convaincre qu'ils
pouvaient faire à les mentionner au
moins longs mois comprend exact je suis
là pour vous et c'est le simple fait de
dire ça et de le dire de le répéter puis
de chaque fois qu'il y va et du bon lait
fermier du sk en scène les mentionne
chaque fois qu'il prend la parole dans
ces états là déjà c'est un peu plus que
ce que d'autres ont fait a besoin même
puis byden va essayer de faire la même
chose mais je pense que bernie sanders
disais la même maudite affaire quatre
ans c'est à dire faut aider les
travailleurs dans ces secteurs en déclin
les mots dix accords de commerce tout ça
et son discours au poignet quand même au
midwest monsieur center on le voyait si
on parle un peu de beurre nice 1-2
justement puis de sa campagne moi je
quand je suivais un petit peu sur les
élections démocrates en fait pis il
semblait en bonne augure pour être pour
gagner ou du moins être compétitif qui
est il ya eu un switch journée qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour que bernie faso est
ce qu'on ne m'aime pas d'autres
nationale vote le vote donne à gagner
grâce à sammy du va lancer dans ses
voiles et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement avec bernie qui semble être
bien
de bonne augure en fait avant en
rentrant loeb finalement si je suis
écroulé mais il ya 2-3 affaire il ya le
vote à froid dire que je pense que c'est
important bunny bunny ça ne va pas à pas
travailler peut-être pas assez travaillé
de ce côté-là instant sénateur du
vermont de nouvelle angleterre il est
très connu dans le midwest très connu
dans plusieurs états américains
il a peut-être moins développés à ces
liens dans les états du sud qui
deviennent importants surtout la carline
dessus d'un certain moment dans la
séquence des primaires
donc on est arrivé en caroline ceux dont
le vus bernie sanders a eu beaucoup de
difficulté à courtiser cet électorat-là
qui se tourner plutôt vers dubaï donne
mais y'a deux autres choses qui sont
produites et qui ont fortement nui à
bernie sanders
je dirais une autre chose c'est qu'à un
moment donné au sein du parti démocrate
il ya beaucoup de candidats qui sont
tournés vers ben hayden et qu'ils ont
appuyé dans une séquence très très
rapide beau dj jimmy claude atcher un
peu autour de la de la primaire de la
caroline du sud et à baden est devenu
une espèce de candidat de compromis et
l'espèce de candidats bouillon de poulet
dont je parle est à nos yeux de bien des
démocrates qui se demandent est-ce
bernie sanders pouvait gagner cette
élection en profitent de leur barack
obama aussi c'est une profite boutique
le rabbin moi et je pense est encore
très populaire
je pense a été somme toute un bon
président mais que pau pu réaliser
jusqu'à révolue réaliste riposte globale
de la deuxième chance de réaliser toutes
ces choses le oui et puis le fait que
ben laden soit peu plus soit populaire
auprès des électeurs à froid me
reconnaissais pas étranger au fait qui a
été vice président d'obama aussi ont le
droit comme le body d'obama lab
romançant barack obama joe biden mais
byden georges janvier ça fait une
quarantaine d'années qui en politique
comme je disais tantôt jeu quand je les
rencontre et au new hampshire
j'ai pu vérifier une chose qu'on dit
souvent propos de joe boyd joe biden
c'est toi qui le disais tantôt c'est pas
le le politicien plus le plus
charismatique
quand tu écoutes un discours bon il y
lit le texte sur le téléprompteur bon ça
vaut mais mais c'est pas le discours qui
est portant avec joe biden c'est ce qui
se passe après le discours et ce sont
des choses que les gens ne voient pas
nécessairement la télévision quand le
vus à manchester au new hampshire
j'étais là byden était à peu près où
vous vous êtes peut-être aux livres
derrière vous donc j'entends le discours
j'écoute le discours une vingtaine de
minutes après cela les caméras ferme
hebeisen pense 1h30 2h dans la salle a
serré la main de tout le monde tout le
monde
un parent pose des question qui êtes
vous d'où venez vous pourquoi êtes vous
ici
et quand on dit que c'est une bonne
personne je sais qu'on met beaucoup
l'accent là-dessus en vue de 2020 il ya
des gens qui disent ouais on exagère un
peu
oui on exagère toujours un peu en
campagne électorale mais il le fait sous
la poignée de main à tout cela il ya des
gens qui disaient que s'approche un peu
trop d des électrices parfois un
politicien est active
mais on a fait un petit il s'est redit
mais ils partagent encore enjoint
d'impact même en 2020 claire des réseaux
sociaux puis ça a un certain impact
auprès de auprès des gens qui sont en
détresse en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
gens en détresse dans ce pays là il faut
pas l'oublier on parlait des
afro-américains tout à l'heure qui
manifestent après l'assassinât de
georges floyd des gens du midwest qui
qui avait un job où il gagnait cent
mille dollars par année il ya 20 ans qui
aujourd'hui ont quatre jobs cygan 40000
dollars par année aux 25 et 4 par année
il ya beaucoup de détresse dans ce pays
là et le simple fait de de rencontrer un
candidat qui prend une minute pour te
parler moi je pense ça peut faire la
différence
si je dis que ton pote le suisse alain
pigeon tech toi c'est ce que ton pays
très bon là dedans
comme des millions c'est sur canal alors
lakovic 19 ce document mais byron a fait
la politique comme ça pendant plusieurs
décennies et ça lui a permis entre
autres par jour soit mais de bâtir la
coalition des lecteurs dont je parlais
tantôt des lectrices dont je parlais
tantôt il est venu me voir un moment
donné puis je dis monsieur bart hayden
je suis canadien n'aurait profondeur en
fait vous important pour vous donc je
comprendrais tout à fait si vous n'avez
pas le temps de me parler
nous allons je veux quand même prendre
le temps de parler puis pour la petite
histoire dans ma thèse de doctorat il ya
70 pages sur joe biden g j'ai publié ma
thèse en fait j'ai terminé ma thèse en
2008 c'était avant qu'il soit
vice-président et c'était sur son rôle
au sénat sur les questions de politique
étrangère
j'étudie à quatre sénateurs dont dubaï
de pelé dit pourquoi êtes vous là bas on
étudie les élections j'avais que des
chercheurs de mon centre de recherche et
tout ça puis 10 h content de vous
rencontrer parce qu'il ya 80 pages de ma
pèsent sur votre parcours au sénat en
aliments par nice et chouchou est en
train de prendre le temps de gens qui
ont probablement plus besoin que moi de
lui parler il ya quand même pris un deux
trois minutes pour que je lui raconte
cette affaire là et puis il ya son
directeur de campagne
peux tu prends le courriel de
de frédéric j'aimerais ça lire sa tête
en français monsieur le vice-président
d'angers lille français envoie ta tête
puis je vais te revenir là dessus il
m'est parvenue là dessus le samedi sa
première phase il me revient pas là
dessus mais s'était convertie en ce
moment il va d'une place à une place
plus tard vient la tulle
y a pas le temps puis échotiers je
prends important pour 2 mai mais c'était
juste intéressant de le voir ali et je
trouve que à la télé c'est le genre
d'affaires qu'on ne voit pas mais qui
est important qui reste important je
pense en politique et j'ai vu bernie
sanders en iowa j'ai vu elizabeth warren
au les autres tous vu et baï donné celui
qui de tous les démocrates que j'ai vu
de tous les candidats que j'ai vue
républicain démocrate est celui qui fait
le plus et je pense que ça ça fait une
différence
c'est super intéressant
puis ça nous fait un excellent pivot
pour commencer pour parler de biovail
donne dans le oui mais à mais en fait
atteinte à 13 en partie sur lui quel
genre de quel genre de carrière
politique est ce qu'ils ont mené puis
quel genre de président ce que ce serait
ça ce que j'imagine que tu est
extrêmement bien placé pour le connaître
avant même si tu l'as bien étudié avant
qu'ils soient vice-présidente la
précieuse machine que tu te continue à
le suivre cool
oui c'est vraiment c'est quelqu'un
d'assez pragmatique quand je pense que
c'est un mot qu'on doit retenir à propos
de sa carrière puis d'ailleurs c'est une
de ses faiblesses aussi pour certains
parce que ces positions ont évolué puis
prête flanc à la critique à des moments
où il était plus conservateur sur les
questions raciales
il ya des gens qui lui disent en ce
moment elle est il est devenu plus
progressistes sur ces questions là mais
je dirais qu'en 40 ans de carrière le
temps de changer ton avis danger
avis changement dans ma vie tu est un
peu c'est que les fous mais si j'en
reviens à ma description de la société
américaine de tantôt l'ôter swan
canadiens soit nordique le fait d'avoir
un candidat qui a changé d'idée en
arrière ça peut ça peut être une
faiblesse parce que les gens peuvent
dire à ça c'était mauvais dans le passé
ça c'était mauvais mais mais c'est
quelqu'un d'assez pragmatique quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui justement c'est pas c'est
pas le fait que bernie sanders décide de
l'appuyer cette année alors que c'était
plus difficile avec madame clinton en
2016 n'est pas étrange en fait le fait
qu'ils soient pragmatiques monsieur bart
hayden explique sans en partie ce soit
qu'on veut battre on peut aussi mais
bayonne durant les primaires a tout de
suite tendu la main à bernie sanders et
à ses partisans disant on va former
on va former des comités qui on va
rédiger la plateforme électorale du
parti démocrate ensemble donc si vous
regardez la plateforme du parti
démocrate ce que vous constatez c'est
que c'est probablement où c'est
peut-être la plateforme électorale la
plus à gauche de notre histoire récente
de ce parti là il ya beaucoup d'idées
dans le programme électoral de baden qui
sont carrément inspiré de bernie sanders
ok on accorde une grande importance aux
questions environnementales
on veut augmenter les impôts l'un pour
les riches
d'ailleurs ça peut lui nuire en ce
moment parce que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont allergiques aux augmentations
d'impôts aux états unis mais quand même
byden dit on doit augmenter les impôts
des plus riches les gens qui gagnent
plus de 400 mille dollars par année les
impôts des entreprises choses auxquelles
tu as juste dire tu as fais juste dans
tout le temps il veut augmenter vos
impôts élevés remarque tu es fou d'un
pauvre a wish you love me
400 millions 10 les plus riches ce genre
c'est vraiment les plus riches mais
c'est ça dont dans la plateforme
électorale du parti démocrate il ya
l'option publique
pour ce qui est de l'assurance santé
donc on voit un petit peu plus loin que
ce que barack obama avait proposé à
l'époque mais on va pas jusqu'à bernie
sanders en disant que font un système de
santé un payeur unique semblable à celui
qu'on est au canada
mais quand même la plateforme électorale
et est très à gauche et ici c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui au stade de sa
carrière va essayer de jouer le rôle de
rassembler n'hésitera pas à déléguer
aussi des gens qui au sein de son
administration voudraient tenter d'aller
de l'avant avec une politique très très
à gauche sur un enjeu d'ailleurs ce sera
intéressant de voir si bernie sanders
aura un poste au sein d'une
administration byden ce n'est pas
impossible et je pense que ce sera un
peu une espèce de s'il était lui bien
sûr une espèce de d'administration de
deux coalitions ou by dane et
rassemblant les confie à certains
membres de son administration de grandes
responsabilités sur les questions
environnementales tu veux tu grattes est
sympa avec le dossier puis va essayer de
convaincre le congrès d'aller de l'avant
avec de grandes réformes sur ce plan là
ça me dérange pas je pense d'un peu
l'attitude de bae dont six avec trompant
d'un gouvernement d'une personne n'a
fait une administration d'une personne
avec bach haydn on aurait une
administration dit qu'il dise vraiment
le team work c'est comme ça qu'on le
conçoit et baida n'a pas le choix de le
concevoir comme ça parce que c'est quand
même un candidat qui a ses faiblesses
manque à ces faiblesses qui a qui avons
parlé du charisme tantôt l'énergie
l'énergie veut veut pas 77 ans ça se
peut que quatre ans ce soit long à cet
âge là aussi le oui est souvent il le
dit il se voit quand même s'il est élu
un président de transition vers autre
chose et c'est là où les jeunes du parti
démocrate dont on a parlé tantôt la
pourrais je pense dès la prochaine
élection
en place plus importante prendre une
place plus importante kamala harris sa
colistière aussi représentent l'avenir
du parti serait pas étonnant de la voir
se présenter à nouveau la prochaine fois
et c'est un peu ça l'histoire des
parties ressemblent un peu à ça des fois
on sent qu'on est proche d'une
transformation majeure au sein du parti
démocrate mais c'est comme si on était
mais ça s'arrange l'élément transitaires
qui se trouve être de quoi de plus
neutre plus générique plus ouais plus
coquille cookies côté surtout dans le
contexte actuel il démocrates ont
vraiment pas de l'échappée on n y avait
pas de l'échappée ils ont encore peur de
l'échappée il ya une expression en ce
moment dont on parle beaucoup c'est le
le syndrome post traumatique de 2016
les démocrates l'ont échappé en ce qu'il
avait pu lancer qu'il avait level paul
l'échappée parce que quatre autres
années de trump donc j'en viens à
buydens pas un candidat parfait mais il
ya beaucoup de gens au sein du parti qui
avait l'impression que bernie sanders
est un petit peu trop révolutionnaire
pour tout ça prenait pour ce que ça
prend ce moment ci c'est à dire je veux
reprendre la maison blanche enjoint
enjoint safe finalement puis dans cette
reprise la maison blanche que ça m'amène
à parler parler d'autre chose que je
voulais qu'on parle aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que tu parlais tout à l'heure
que depuis le début de sa présidence
trump essaie d'attirer les limites de la
démocratie puis ça fait mal ça fait ça
ça doit faire de zinc c'est clair comme
de l'eau de roche que ce qui est cette
force et de planifier des l'utilisation
des élections à chaque étape ighli
symbole un moulin mollahs pour
délégitimiser le processus d'élection
qu'est ce que tu penses
en fait la question sait plus ce qu'est
ce que tu commentes entrevoit les
élections commente entrevoit un résultat
serré 10 qui va s'ensuivre on obtient on
en parle souvent de est ce que tu es
prêt à laisser le pouvoir
une transition de pouvoir normal piles
et justine puis a jamais répondu à ce
est toujours dit que celle ja oui aussi
aussi quoi c'est comment tu comment tu
vois c'est ce que tu crois que
réellement
il ya un danger pour la démocratie dans
les deux prochaines semaines
je pense que oui je pense qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer ce risque
je pense que trump pourrait être tenté
d'entretenir l'ambiguïté pendant après
l'élection le soir d'élection après
l'élection et pendant la période de
transition aussi une qui mène à
l'arrivée de la prochaine administration
au pouvoir se trouve à 15 et le 20
janvier donc quand le trou en avant mais
le 20 janvier
you [ __ ] ya du temps est ce que tu
rome va faire va beaucoup dépendre
je dirais de la clarté avec laquelle les
gens votent byden le 3 novembre
est-ce que ce résultat est clair ou
pourtant dit du cerf ou pour mango et ce
qui est encore plus compliquée cette
fois ci c'est que étant donné la
pandémie les états ont permis il ya plus
d'états qui ont permis le vote par
correspondance le vote par la poste et
il ya des états qui acceptent de compter
des vols après le 3 9 ans et beaucoup
d'états clé de l'élection la
pennsylvanie en étant l'ohio en étant il
ya des états qui vont compter des votes
jusqu'à deux semaines fait qu'on va pas
se coucher le 620 en ceci qu'il préside
un tel droit le 3e oui mais ça se peut
que le 6 on sache mais c'est ce que
j'allais dire et pas tout à fait dans
l'erreur de penser que c'est possible je
dirais que 3 vous allez regarder la
soirée l'exception que oui l'a3 en avant
on sait pas encore sur quelques shine on
veut quelque chose d'impartial le 3
novembre je vous dirais la floride est
un est à surveiller
j'ai toujours un état clé de l'élection
mais c'est un des états qui n'acceptent
pas de compter des votes harel trois
enfants
le problème c'est que c'est tout le
temps série donc on sera peut-être pas
le 3 l'avant et ça se peut qu'on sache
avant minuit et traille donne semblait
quand même beaucoup en avance dans les
poses en floride
oui ça sert sert un petit peu le cours
des dernières semaines ils sont
peut-être un deux points d'avancé en
floride en ce moment 2 3 qui stocke
aussi que depuis plusieurs années c'est
l'état qui détermine le qui souvent que
la floride et décide finalement fait sa
fille parce qu'en un état toujours
important c'est l'état qui avait fait la
différence en 2000 notamment quand il ya
eu le recomptage dans la dans l'élection
pour autant wbo chago donc c'est l'état
qui avait fait scandale à ce moment là
mais si on sait que byden gagne la faune
la flore et le 3 novembre avant minuit
ont ce rapport on sera peut-être pas qui
a gagné en pennsylvanie on saura
peut-être pas qu'il gagne en ohio sion
si on tient pour acquis qu'on va compter
des votes après le trop en avant mais
trump a vraiment besoin de la floride
pour gagner l'élection
si par la floride le 3 il ya déjà des
prix des analyses qui vont dire est ce
qu'un ebit de fuck off bla bla bla il ya
peut-être à ce moment en laye dans les
jours qui vont suivre des républicains
qui vont commencer à dire se trompent le
cétacé on a ici par la floride ça se
peut qu'un acquis le boss de son propre
parti qui fasse le passé la floride
l'arizona
je pense que tu rends pas besoin de la
floride et de l'arizona pour gagner en
fait il doit gagner la floride l'ohio la
georgie l'iowa la deuxième
circonscription du maine la caroline du
nord se sont j'en oublie peut-être mais
déjà les états que je vous ai nommé là
c'est très très serré entre les deux et
by dane est en avance dans peut-être la
moitié de ces états là où c'est très
très serré en tout cas donc si tu rome
on le voit le soir d'élection est en
difficulté dans ces états et par la
floride
ça devient très difficile pour lui de
gagner l'élection et si c'est pas ça rit
pendant tout parce que il ya des gens
qui disent ça peut être serré mais ya
aussi les pronostiqueurs qui dit ça se
peut que ce soit en slide démocrates
aussi c'est à dire un raz de marée
démocrate parce que il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de vote par anticipation six
fois plus qu'à l'habitude à huawei
il ya beaucoup de votes parmi ces votes
là qui sont des votes acquis à baden
non ça c'est déjà dans la basse et
surtout des gens qu ainsi à la base je
pense que plus
plus de participation est élevée plus
avantagés démocrate oui oui parce que si
le taux de participation est très très
très élevé ce que ça veut dire c'est que
les électeurs issus des minorités
ethnoculturelles ont réussi à s'inscrire
un petit peu plus sur les listes
électorales au chaud la game de tram
c'est de faire sortir son vote aussi qui
va sortir fort en principe d'ici le 3 en
avant mais surtout le 3 novembre
et là je vous dirai ceci le 3 novembre
quand vous allez regarder la soirée
électorale faut faire attention parce
que les votes par correspondance dans
certains états auront été dépouillés en
fait on les aura compté 1 avant le 3
novembre
ils les résultats qu'on va avoir tout en
soirée dans plusieurs états ça va être
beaucoup démocrates et les républicains
revenaient après ça on va compter les
votes qui ont été enregistrées le jour
du vote sur sound un peu plus république
est donc le soir du 3 novembre 6 à 8 3
dans le dernier col à gagner pour faire
attention ça va ça peut se stabiliser
dans l'autre sens on fait aller dans
l'autre sens durant la soirée
mais c'est ça qui est problématique
c'est qu'il ya plusieurs états clefs où
ça risque d'être serrée et où il va
falloir attendre qu'on est content et
tous les votes
après le trou en avant peut-être trois
quatre jours après une semaine après
deux semaines après pour savoir qui a
gagné 6 est serré et c'est là où ce que
tu disais tantôt l'autre homme fait quoi
dans ce contexte-là j'entrevois pas de
problème là je me suis me trompe mais si
c'est un vote serré qui voit démocrate
j'ai quand même pas un bon et surtout
cisma contesté que j'ai d exiger des
recomptages tout seul devant moi on a
sorti leur paul way i 10 rebelles vote
par la poste
c'était épique étudier sa game se fasse
sentir son vote mais sa game c'est aussi
de ne pas faire sortir le vote du cirad
petit j emploie titre de stratagèmes
pour limiter l'accessibilité au vote par
correspondance à l'inscription sur des
listes et puis ça me paraît tellement
antidémocratique que manière de faire
des limites et le l'accès au vote des
citoyens les gens riaient ce que je
disais tantôt le fameux cynisme dont tu
parlais ils vont tout faire pour gagner
ils vont tout faire pour gagner et le
problème c'est un chercheur accepté le
texte à y rentrer
rui teixeira qui a écrit et d'autres qui
ont écrit là-dessus l'avenir
démographique aux états unis avantage en
principe le parti démocrate parce que tu
assiste à une montée en importance des
latino américains notamment qui vote
surtout démocrate et tout ça donc les
républicains réalise que le bassin de
vote qu'il aurait acquis diminue diminue
au fur et à mesure qu'on avance dans le
temps donc sitôt passée de vote pour
gagner tu fais quoi tu essaie d'empêcher
le parti adverse de de faire le plein de
votes le jour de l'élection
puis dans plusieurs états c'est pas
juste roms dans plusieurs états on a on
a des gouverneurs républicains des
législatures républicaine des élus
républicains qui essaient de décourager
le vote de supprimer le vote en floride
on a rendu une décision importante où on
a dit que il y a tous ces électeurs qui
ont une dette judiciaire qui ne devrait
pas voter sur sa touche un million
d'électeurs
et ça fait une différence la floride
je viens d'en parler c'est un état où
c'est toujours serré si tu enlèves un
bassin potentiel d'un million de votes
au parti démocrate
c'est ce qu'il est devenu aussi excuse
moi il est détenu aussi je pense qu'ils
vont principalement démocrate qu'on
essaie d'empêcher le droit de sol
souvent on va on va on va on va obliger
des gens à se réinscrire sur les listes
électorales après un certain temps est
généralement ces pratiques là on le voit
des avantages les électeurs issus des
minorités
parce que bon pour des raisons que j'ai
évoquées tantôt on n'a peut-être pas le
temps parce qu'on travaille beaucoup on
a peut-être pas de voiture pour soit
rendu là où il faut aller chercher la
documentation tout ça donc il ya toutes
sortes de stratagèmes comme ça et ça
c'est dans toute l'histoire des états
unis mais ça existantes en 2020
mais il ya quand même le système
électoral danois qui fonctionne qui est
qui un peu archaïque le faut se le dire
avantage quand même les républicains
parce que le ca fait en 2016 puis en
2000 avec al gore phi phi bouche très où
est ce que les démocrates avaient la
majorité d'un nombre de votes et que
c'est quand même un président
républicain pas qu'ici il y aussi ce
système le qu'avantage en partie ouais
le système du collège électoral qu'on
utilise pour élire le président avantage
le parti républicain sont le vu les deux
élections auxquelles tu ferais faire en
fonction de bons de bons exemples
et là bas il y a des gens qui propose
des réformes mais c'est sais pas ce sera
pas d'ici le 3 en avant mais c'est quand
même compliqué à mettre en oeuvre il ya
déjà deux états qui attribuent leur
leurs votes au collège électoral d'une
autre manière le nebraska et le maine où
on peut obtenir des votes au collège
électoral sont remporte la partie dans
les circonscriptions de l'étang plus de
du vote qui exprime et dans l'état bon
je veux pas trop entrer dans les détails
mais il ya des gens qui propose qu'on
qu'on devrait attribuer les votes au
collège électoral à la proportionnelle
parce qu'en ce moment ce qui se passe
ici tu soit un vote de plus si tu
termines premier en votes exprimés le
soir de l'élection dans 48 dans 48 et
autres soient tous les votes au collège
électoral rattache à cet état en
californie en 1 55 je pense si tu es
premier en votes exprimés par les
électeurs en californie le soir de
l'élection
tu vois les 55 votes au collège
électoral rattaché à cet état et c'est
pour ça bon c'est un système qui
en sorte que si tu gagnes la bonne
combinaison d'état c'est toi qui devient
président même si le moindre vote au
pays que ton adversaire mais et
surveiller ce en 2020 c'est pas
impossible que trump réussissent encore
à gagner la présidence comme ça il
pourrait perdre ou nationale par trois
millions quatre millions de votes mais
gagner quand même la bonne combinaison
d'état qui lui permet de garder les clés
de la maison blanche
et puis jusqu'où ça peut aller le fait
qu'ils s'accrochent pouvoir s'y dit que
je refuse la légitimité des élections là
le vote par correspondance est une
fraude nanana ici il s'attache au lit
dans la maison blanche si en plus mais
ton et sa garde rapprochée de ses îles
et continue le bac est là dedans je
jusqu'où tu es si physiquement ils sont
pas de la maison blanche est ce qu'on
fait on envoie l'armée cherchait on a
posé la question à dubaï donne à un
moment donné qui qui a fini par répondre
cela dit je vais demander à ce qu'on
l'escort puis faisait référence
probablement aux militaires cherchez la
femme peut pas se faire acheter son
jouet préféré c'est ce genre de scénario
qu'on voit dans des séries télé ou dans
tout le pays
c'est justement dans un autre pays
cigales à des réflexes si prédicateur
extrait on s'entend là-dessus il admire
en tout cas ce genre de chefs d'état
sont le vu kim jong-un
j'échange les lettres d'amour et oui
johnny de la relation tellement cordiale
dans le livre avec bob woodward c'est
tellement drôle
la mana qui s'échangent c'est vraiment
des lettres d'amour qui s'appelle votre
excellence picsou qui l'aï dit il dit
dans notre homme est tellement fier
tiens qui se fait appeler votre
excellence parking john la première fois
c'est vraiment particulier matin andré
qui plus proches de dédé poutine dépit
d'aidés de lille dans nord coréen que
des pays tels que trudeau par exemple
oui j'en reviens ce que je disais tantôt
roja quand les coups de parler ils
utilisent souvent des termes comme fort
puissant pour décrire les gens qui
l'entourent is strong mai
à iso stranglers je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui aime ce type de leadership
des leaders forts qu'on ne critique pas
trop qu'ils sont capables de faire taire
la critique souvent ils avaient dit des
médias dont six qui dit des médias mais
je pense qu'il avait dit après une
visite en corée du nord je pense qu'ils
étaient il était un retour aux états
unis il avait dit quand kim jong-un par
les médias ou en fait le peuple l'
écoute puis des fois je me suis fait pas
ce qu'il avait dit exactement mais ça
ressemble à ça plus on pouvait sentir
une espèce dans envie que ça se passe
comme si aux etats-unis aussi un
d'ailleurs on le voit la manière dont
ils traitent les médias encore dans six
rallyes récemment c'est toujours la même
histoire mais yo crutchlow et blablabla
on vous montre pas les grosses foules
qui est ici vous devriez apprendre
d'autres plantes caméra pour montrer à
quel point on aime et on m'a puis donc
clairement il ya clairement une
fascination en tout cas pour ces leaders
un petit peu plus fort ils essaient
d'incarner ça mais ils évoluent dans un
système qui permet au président fernand
ce qui veut donc un clash
le bref on peut s'attendre à un cas où
lé tro novembre je pense si le résultat
de l'élection est clair moi je pense que
les républicains du congrès vont dire
monsieur 36 fini et ça va difficile pour
lui de de penser sérieusement à rester
si c'est très serré moi je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir des affrontements au
sein de la société américaine entre
groupes un peu comme ce qu'on voit dans
les villes entourant justement l'affairé
djordje floyd mais des affrontements
comme centre group qui exige le départ
de trump dans les rues aux manifestants
et des groupes un peu plus à droite qui
qui sont également dans les rues et oui
ça peut mener à des affrontements
violents
je pense qu'on parle de guerre civile
moi je pense qu'on va un peu loin de la
guerre civile américaine c'était autre
chose mais des affronts main en cas de
résultat d'une élection de résultats
serrés à cette élection là où il ya une
espèce de controverse entourant l'idée
ou pas de ne reconnaître
d'organes l'idée au pas de reconnaître
telle ou telle voie où on a un président
qui dit moi je pars pas tant que c'est
pas réglé où on a des mouvements qui
disent il faut qu'ils partent parce
qu'il a perdu
wassa scénario inquiète à quel point est
ce que l'armée est indépendante de la
présidence
c'est au sens social youtube youtube des
dirigeants de l'armée américaine qui
pourrait dire là il ya eu des élections
il ya eu un vrai un résultat on établit
l'ordre piste et on on protège le pub
pour pas que sayyed et débordant des
bouts de débordements peu importe qui
est le président si on regarde la
constitution des états unis
les deux choses à retenir la première
c'est que le président des états unis
est décrit dans la constitution comme en
commettant le commandant en chef des
forces armées
donc en principe les militaires sont son
régime par l'ue sont tenus de suivre un
de suivre ses indications et ses
décisions l'autre chose que l'on doit
retenir à propos de la constitution
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun mécanisme qui
prévoit ce qu'on est dans ce qu'on est
en train de parler qui permet de régler
ce genre de problème là c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui voudrait qu'ils voudraient
pas quitté le podium arrive il n'y a
rien dans la constitution qui nous
permet de savoir quoi faire
donc est ce que les militaires
pourraient être tentés de d'escorté
trump ci décide de s'accrocher au
pouvoir
c'est très difficile à c'est très
difficile pour moi de zéro et c'est
possible de soi mais je sais pas on est
vraiment dans l'inconnu
on aime j'aimerais dire j'aimerais avoir
ma petite boule de cristal mais matt
j'aimerais lire dans le café au lait
dans le café mais j'avoue que ça ça
dépasse ça dépasse le genre de scénario
que j'ai pu auxquels j'ai pu penser
depuis que je suis la politique
américaine
enfin on souhaite vraiment pratiquement
lenzerheide démocrate pendule
les démocrates souhaitent en soit ça et
et on les voit beaucoup dire les
sondages il faut pas il faut aller me
restitue gants et bottes du gameplay
élections avec nos sondages quand les
élections en battle exactement parce
qu'en 2016 ça a été ça un petit peu le
problème aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont restés ont dû
s'asseoir dessus en faisant les
démocrates vont bien bref de toute façon
madame clinton je trie pas trop ça me
tente pas nécessairement d'aller lui
donner mon vote et va regagner de toute
façon là cette fois ci c'est différent
parce que les démocrates voient l'enjeu
de non participation à cette élection là
si ça se décide en 2016 là ça s'est
décidé
ce sont vraiment moins de cent mille
votes qui ont fait la différence dans
trois états le risque en chine le
michigan la pennsylvanie
donc c'est pas grand chose moins de
100000 vote sur plus de 720 millions de
votes là quand tu vois ça tu réalises
que ton vote personnel peut devenir très
très important l'enjeu est grand c4
entre hommes ou autre chose
c'est pour ça que je pense que le taux
de participation risque d'être élevée
les démocrates veulent aller voter mais
les partisans de rome veulent aller
voter houssin donc ça va être record des
très rares quand je pense qu'on pourrait
se dire je mettrais peut-être un petit
deux là dessus tout autant qu'ils le
disent à rien ces dernières qui longeait
dernière question juste par intérêt
personnel avant de laisser partir et ce
qu est ce qu'on peut imaginer
pardon une présidente occasion porteuse
éventuellement oui oui oui parce que moi
je suis je serai le levant le gars le
plus heureux
la planète elle est extrêmement
populaire extrêmement talentueuse elle a
le sens de la formule et qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas avec elle je pense que
les gens à droite
aux etats unis sont conscients
consciente de ça aussi c'est maintenant
c'est un nom à surveiller je pense
qu'elle est elle s'inscrit tout à fait
dans la suite de ce que bonnie saleuses
a pu représenter peut-être un petit peu
plus pragmatique aussi c'est à dire
capable de de dialoguer avec les gens un
petit peu plus au centre au sein du
parti mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle
va renoncer à ses idées et ali
extrêmement talentueuse jeu moi je pense
que c'est un nom qu'on doit absolument
garder à l'esprit
et comme impossible on dirait à mettre
dans un coin andré kuhn départ du
batteur une batteuse commentaires reçus
on repart pas l'excellent est excellente
et je parlais de sa tante où il ya
beaucoup de
il ya beaucoup de d'élus aux états unis
qui ne savent pas comment maîtriser
cette façon-là de communes je sais pas
combien de millions à la sur instagram
voici quelques-uns en audio on parle des
réseaux sociaux parce qu'on le voit mais
pas nécessairement connaissance un
exemple montrer mon téléphone est ce que
je suis en train de dire c'est que joe
byden mène une bonne campagne sur les
médias sociaux en ce moment mais c'est
pas lui qui l'amène au caire parce que
c'est pas c'est pas de sa génération
sais pas barack obama était très bon
bunny sein deux excellents aussi mais il
ya des gens autour de lui qui l'ont aidé
en année cette campagne très efficace
sur les médias sociaux au casot cortese
s'entoura bien à ce niveau mais elle
comprend ce fait pisser justice ginsburg
est décédé à le fait un long live qui
était vu par des millions et des
millions de personnes wasquehal expliqué
comme un conte comment continuer le
combat comment continuer à avoir cette
idée l'antenne depuis
puis s'est littéralement plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes dès
millions personnes qui ont vu se sait ça
et d une conférence de presse en faire
mais impromptue que je fais comme tu
veux quand tu veux en faisant le message
que tu veux puis ça fonctionne et il ya
vraiment des effets générationnels
en politique il ya des cas barack obama
fait campagne en 2008
gt gt prof est invité sur la côte ouest
et je voyais des jeunes en mi-court me
dire merci beaucoup c'était vraiment le
fun mais là je dois quitter bon à la fin
du cours
les gens partent à vide où allez-vous on
va donner du temps pour la campagne de
barack obama
et barack obama ont réussi à fidéliser
une génération d'électeurs qui sont
encore acquis au parti démocrate
aujourd'hui occasion cortese bas dont
tout le monde y est elle est excellent
je te rappelle est vraiment bonne et
cela elle est en train de fidéliser les
électeurs les électrices de demain dans
ce parti là et je vous dirais que quand
je regarde les deux parties je suis pas
mal moins inquiet pour le parti
démocrate quand je roule l'acteur joe
cortez que je le serai
du côté républicain ou d'un autre homme
à occuper tout l'espace pendant quatre
ans et honnêtement on s'est un petit peu
quels sont les visages de demain du côté
républicain mais c'est moins évident du
côté démocrate
il ya moins de relève parce que tout le
monde s'est assis sur ses lauriers en
quelque sorte en attendant de voir ce
qui se passera avec trente petits
tromper réélu pour quatre ans a fait une
grosse différence c'est hyper mal le
parti républicain va devoir se
reconstruire un ami qui est l'hypothèse
peut-être certains disaient dans notre
homme junior est mort mais je trouve
qu'il ya un peu plus pesos et
indépendamment de mes opinions
politiques je trouve qu'il n'ya plus
d'avenir en ce moment dans le parti
démocrate qui peut y en avoir dans le
parti républicain si je regarde la
relève unis occasion cortès fait
clairement partie de ceux aussi j'ai une
dernière question par du volet quand tu
as l'impression que c'était cette
élection-là est extrêmement décisive si
finalement l'as rome va voir était une
aberration de parenthèse bizarres des
leçons des états unis
hook est aussi réélue un espèce de
moment qui va complètement transformer
le visage des etats-unis profondément
paraître excessivement pour ce difficile
de revenir de ce puits après ce deuxième
volet commandant dépenses dans vingt et
un ans on va percevoir le président le
très beau tir qui a six est passé
c'était quoi ce où ça veut savoir
devenir une normalité où ça va être un
président comme un autre je pense que
les quatre premières années de 3 nous
ont montré ce à quoi pourrait ressembler
la politique américaine c'est le reste
au pouvoir pour un long moment je pense
que s'il est réélu pour quatre ans sa
vision de la politique américaine ce
qu'il a proposé sa manière de faire son
côté les attaques personnelles et tous
étaient là avant 3-1 électrum c'est sur
les stéroïdes
il pense que s'il est réélu pour quatre
ans ils vont inspirer justement d'autres
d'autres jeunes républicains à faire la
politique comme ça
pourquoi parce que ça marche on peut on
peut conclure que ça marche ça permet de
gagner des élections ça permet de tirer
son épingle du jeu et on voit déjà des
républicains qui tentent de faire la
politique comme il l'a fait dans des
publicités télévisées on a vu toutes
sortes de choses évidemment c'est moins
visé parce que ce sont ceux sont des
gens moins connus que trump qui le font
mais cette idée qu'on doit attaquer
cette idée qu'on ne doit pas faire de
compromis tout ça c'est en train de le
soufflé est en train de prendre et
encore plus qu'avant parce que trump si
gang va démontrer que ça peut être
payant sur le plan électoral
donc ça fait une grande différence s'il
est réélu s'il ne fait qu'un mandat ben
oui on parlera peut-être un peu plus de
cette présidence comme étant une parente
est ce vers quoi on aurait pu aller mais
on a décidé de faire autrement
c'est une bonne question puis pour ce
qui est du regard historique on fait du
regard qu'on va porter sur cette
présidence là dans 20 ans mais ça c'est
drôle parce que des fois les historiens
au début dit sur certaines très mauvaise
présidence mais réévaluent après coup
peut penser à george w bush mais
maintenant le comparateur hommes c'est
sûr qui paraît peut-être mieux que comme
pour ceux qui a été critique de ces deux
présidents là parce qu'on va beaucoup
plus loin avec trompe pas encore mais je
pense que dans 20 ans il ya quand même
des gens qui vont qui vont dire que ce
président là est tellement le président
l'histoire
ouais ses partisans sont convaincus il
est le meilleur parce qu'il est le
meilleur président que les états unis
ont eu même dans toute l'histoire de ce
pays la même trempe le dit lui-même ans
de baisse j'ai plus fait pour les
afro-américains qu'est brême linken un
homme et il ya des gens qui sont
convaincus de cela et qu'ils vont rester
convaincu de ce peu importe ce qui se
passe je pense pour les raisons qu'on a
évoqué tantôt les juges la cour suprême
c'est un bon exemple ça s'il est réélu
pour quatre ans a fait tout ça fait une
grosse différence si j'ai le feeling
avec la dernière année puis tout seul
pour reprendre encore une fois l'analyse
et qui disait d'étirer la démocratie
mais j'ai le feeling que s'il est réélu
pour quatre ans ils vont ils vont
essayer d'être élu encore pour quatre
autres années le fantôme et oui le titre
jarrier tellement on dirait que c'est
tellement possible dans ma tête quand
j'ai quand je vois qu'en ce moment il ce
qui est en train de faire par rapport
aux élections puis à discréditer tout ce
je me dis ça me surprendrait même pas
que s'ils résident 80 effacerait je peux
rester encore quatre autres années ouais
il joue un petit peu cette game là aussi
des fois surtout être une voie à l'autre
sur campagne électorale leur trame 2024
je veux dire ça c'est juste comme placer
tranquillement des pions mais il ya un
cadre constitutionnel quand même qui dit
que le président ne peut ne peut pas
faire plus que deux mandats consécutifs
ainsi aussi les directions devrait être
final ces fusées aussi dit la fille il
faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya 74 ans
va donc il ya une limite à ce qui peut
faire lui personnellement mais fait pas
que du sport lui fait qui ira long de sa
vie mais ce que je dirais sexy si réélu
pour quatre ans
là je pense qu'on peut peut-être
commencer à se dire qu'il pourrait y
avoir une dynastie
qui trompe aussi parce que je le disais
un peu tantôt peut-être pas c'était pas
nécessairement la black je le disais
quand je parlais dans notre homme junior
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des ambitions des
ambitions politiques
si son père perd l'élection 2020 ça
devient un petit peu plus difficile pour
les trams de continuer à surfer sur
l'idée qu'ils sont qui sont les gens de
la situation en ce moment mais si sitrom
gagner l'élection 2020 pourquoi pour moi
je pense que son fils pourrait être
tenté de poursuivre sur sa lancée après
ce deuxième mandat dont il serait
peut-être pas trompé lui même qui serait
l'homme on sera un peu dans la même dans
la même dynamique et j'ai pas si vous
avez vu dans notre homme junior mais
c'est vraiment comme son père mais doit
être encore exposants un grand sourire
dans le dans les attaques personnelles
dans c'est vraiment un discours pour la
base et pour la base de la base est-ce
que je dirais par rapport à 36 s'il est
réélu il aura l'impression d'avoir le
monde de continuer ce qu'il a en année
pendant quatre ans et je pense qu'il va
y aller encore plus à fond très nous
dans que il n'aura pas le stress il aura
plus d'élection est rude le prix lui
simplement il rend pas le stress d'être
réélu après bon peut-être qui pensera à
l'avenir politique de son fils rendu
l'on verra mais je vois pas pourquoi
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas changé de
ton ni de discours en quatre ans et demi
en cinq ans si on inclut les mois où il
a pensé se lancer dans la campagne
présidentielle en 2015 la syrie et l'ue
pourquoi je changerais changera pas d u
le virus n'y a pas changé et ne changera
pas si réélu je pense ça va être ça va
être peut-être encore plus affirmé qu
est ce qu on a vu durant les quatre
premières années
donc le choix est quand même clair si on
va tous aux états unis si vous écoutez
aux états unis en ce moment
allez voter parler à tous vos proches
pour aller voter puis fait le choix qui
apparaît évident depuis le début de la
conversation puis même il ya déjà des
électeurs électrices américain qui
habitent à l'extérieur du pays donc des
gens qui habitent montréal
you can volte face à brad si vous pouvez
voter trouver le trouver il faut voter
ces nouveaux votre peau mais on souhaite
quand même que les gens que les gens
votent que l'élection se déroule bien
quand même aussi parce que si on n'est
pas à l'abri de ce genre de situation là
nous non plus au canada les les
démocraties nos systèmes politiques
évoluent et c'est vrai que on en n'est
pas là au canada mais on voit que il ya
des discours aux états unis qui traverse
les frontières aussi il ya des gens ici
qui se sentent inspirés par des choses
qui pourraient représenter quand même
des risques pour nos propres sociétés
donc mais aussi important de s'y
intéresser pour ces raisons là aussi
tout à fait merci infiniment lrc très
intéressant et à merci puis sur ma
prochaine